bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur la défense
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités toujours tenus à bonne distance
et nos reporters sur le terrain
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 8 juillet à chacun son enquête
après l'assemblée nationale des
investigations judiciaires et une
enquête indépendante lancée par l'elysée
le sénat ouvre sa commission sur la
gestion de l'épidémie
kovy de 19 en france les auditions ont
débuté ce soir première entendue et
représentant du grand-est région
particulièrement touchée avec près de
3500 morts relance sur le débat sur
l'hydrologie chloroquine de nouvelles
études contradictoires sur ses
propriétés préventives viennent d'être
publiés la de son côté le professeur
didier raoult l'edt continue de marteler
l'efficacité de ce traitement
alors que le brésilien g1 ball sonar au
annoncé hier se soigner avec c'est une
rupture qui pourrait coûter cher
washington entame son retrait de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
donald trump a mis ses menaces à
exécution il reproche notamment à l' oms
de se montrer trop indulgente à l'égard
de la chine depuis le début de la
pandémie
kobe 10
grand contributeur financier de
l'organisation les etats unis qui
quitteront l'organisation dans un an la
chine pour ses conditions sur un tout
autre dossier celui du nucléaire et
qu'un se dit disposé à discuter d'un
accord russo américain sur l'armement si
washington s'engagent à réduire son
arsenal à sa hauteur les états unis à
dispose d'une réserve dix fois plus
élevée que celle de la chine
[Musique]
après l'assemblée nationale des
investigations judiciaires et une
enquête indépendante lancée par l'elysée
c'est au tour du sénat d'ouvrir une
commission sur la gestion l'épidémie
coville 19 en france
les auditions ont débuté ce soir on
retrouve en direct devant le sénat notre
reporter bcm chez ben hibon soir bassem
qui est auditionné aujourd'hui et
comment vont se dérouler ces auditions
effectivement stéphanie c'est
aujourd'hui que s'ouvre la série
d'auditions organisées par le sénat dans
le cadre de l' enquête sur la gestion de
la crise du corona virus en france des
auditions qui commence aujourd'hui au
sénat en vidéoconférence avec jean
rottner qui est le président de la
région grand est pourquoi la région
grand est est la première à ouvrir le
bal de ces d'auditions organisées par le
sénat tout simplement car la région
grand est a été celle qui a été le plus
touché par le corona virus est celle qui
a commencé à être touchés lors de
l'épidémie vous souvenez vous c'était
lors d'une messe pastorala qu'elle ait
eu lieu dans la région de mulhouse c'est
là qu'on a détecté les premiers cas de
couronnes à virus donc une audition qui
a commencé aujourd'hui notre antenne de
sénateurs sont présents aujourd'hui pour
cette audition en vidéoconférence donc
le président de la région grand est et
répond au fur et à mesure aux
différentes questions des sénateurs
notamment sur la gestion de cette crise
notamment sur les problèmes qu'ils ont
pu avoir au sein même de la région sur
l'inactivité où les lenteurs du
gouvernement est réagir assez rapidement
notamment en ce qui concernait les
masques il a expliqué qu'il a dû
lui-même commenté certains nas qu'il a
eu des problèmes de livraison a dû aux
transporteurs de ces masques qui arrivés
à l'aéroport ils voulaient récupérer les
masques pour sa région plus de 6
millions de masques commandés mais des
militaires qui étaient sur place ont
réquisitionné à tous ses matches donc
voilà différents couacs autour de cette
crise du corona virus les questions
continuent donc toujours en commission
toujours en audition donc c'est le
premier à être entendu
on a pu avoir quelques réactions de
certains sénateurs qui avaient quitté
momentanément la salle notamment jacky
d'euros me dis qu'est sénatrice des
français établis à l'étranger je vous
propose l'écouté savez tout le monde a
entendu parler il ya eu des tas de
problèmes pendant cette période
épouvantable
et donc il est important que nous
puissions faire notre travail de
contrôle savoir s'il ya eu des fautes de
commise et surtout avoir un retour
d'expérience pour ne pas recommencer la
prochaine fois sy sarr ça se reproduit
dans les grès malgré malgré tout ce
qu'il a pu faire il ya quand même eu des
moments de grande panique parce que
parce qu'en effet il n'y avait pas les
masses qui avait pas les produits y
avait pas tout ça et donc qu'ils ont ils
se sont ils ont eu vraiment des moments
où c'était comme la guerre si vous
voulez donc on l'a senti que à certains
moments il était il était plus mettre la
situation et ils ont ils ont paniqué et
donc mais ce qui leur a donné du courage
c'est de d'être ensemble de se
rassembler de voir le la population qui
était derrière eux de voir de voir que
les gens les soutenaient et de voir que
les privés enfin les médecins privés les
les hôpitaux privés etc
tout le monde est allé et tout le monde
a mis sa main à la pâte et et puis alors
après ce grand secours qui est arrivé
l'avion l'hôpital militaire etc tout ça
ça leur a donné confiance et et voilà
ils ont ils ont repris la force mais à
un moment il était sur le point de
lâcher quoi il était vraiment très très
mal alors là il n'a pas fait de reproche
au gouvernement il a dit qu'il
s'attendait pas à ça bien entendu comme
personne et si vous voulez à partir du
moment où il n'y avait personne à aller
dans l'état qui ne qui voulaient passer
les commandes de masques enfin toutes
ces choses là ils ont dû se débrouiller
tout seul donc si vous voulez on peut on
peut reprocher quand on quand on gère un
pays on peut on peut reprocher à nos
gouvernants de ne pas de ne pas avoir ce
qu'il faut de ne pas prévoir les
pandémies des pandémies on sait que ça
arrive et que ça arrivera tout le temps
donc c'est important qu'il y ait ce
qu'il faut qu'il y ait le matériel qu'il
y ait les médicaments et donc donc voilà
donc ça c'est un reproche qui est
constant qui aide qui vient de tout le
monde
vous l'aurez compris l'objectif de cette
commission et de ses différentes
auditions et bien sûr de comprendre ce
qui n'allait pas pour éviter de répéter
les mêmes erreurs en cas de deuxième
vague de pandémie de coronavirus en
france les auditions commencent le
continu pardon à partir de demain ce
sera au tour de la préfète du haut-rhin
josiane chevalier ainsi que du directeur
de la rs et pour le moment c'est
toujours jean rottner qui est un terreau
qui écoute et par an est missionnée par
les membres du sénat dans le cadre des
enquêtes ouvertes dans le cadre de cette
épidémie du cours d'un virus merci ben
hassen chébili en direct du sénat et
dans cette gestion de la crise un an est
revenu souvent l'hydroxyde chloroquine
une étude française publiée hier ne
relève pas de rôle préventif de
l'utilisation au long cours de ce
médicament contre locaux me 10,9 de son
côté le professeur out partisans on le
sait depuis le début de ce traitement
persiste et signe
on fait le point en images
[Rires]
[Musique]
on peut pas empêcher avait été de sortir
depuis finit toujours par sortir et donc
on commence à voir toute une série de
travaux qui sont publiés maintenant et
qui montrent qu'ils tuent en commun
quand on les analyse de montrer tout
qu'il ya une efficacité de notre cycle
au quine 1 dans le traitement de la
maladie et qui évite la mortalité et
deux dans la diminution de la
persistance du virus chez jean
[Musique]
on
où
[Musique]
oh
et dans cette nouvelle vidéo didier
rahout par le même d'intoxication des
esprits vous l'entendrez dans un instant
alors at il raison y at il une grosse
confusion sur ce médicament la france
est-elle à contre-courant du reste du
monde
pourquoi le débat continue t-il avec
autant de vigueur alors que l' oms a mis
un terme officiellement à l'étude de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine comme traitement
potentiel du virus c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir et pour en
parler nous sommes avec thierry
lardinoit médecins généralistes mans du
collectif laissons les médecins à
prescrire bonsoir monsieur bart de noix
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france a beau côté jean-paul à mon
médecin généraliste président de la
fédération des médecins de france
bonsoir à vous jean paul hamon merci
d'être là également sur l'antenne d'arte
et france alors didier raoul temps
évidemment ne lâche rien il a décidé
d'informer lui même le grand public via
les réseaux sociaux son site de vidéos
sur ces études qui montrent un effet
positif de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
est-ce qu'il a raison de se défendre et
surtout de de persister dans cette voie
là thierry lardinoit ah ben moi je pense
qu'il a tout à fait il a tout à fait
raison il a des convictions qui sont
fortes et qui sont basées sur une
expérience personnelle qui est
importante
il a une reconnaissance internationale
il n'y a pas de raison qu'il change
d'avis il va partir du moment où ses
convictions sont fortes et puisque c'est
assez amusant de voir que les drôles si
chloroquine qui a été prescrit à des
milliards de boîtes jusqu'à présent et
qui ne posait pas de problème
particulier personnes se posaient des
questions particulières sur les drogues
si koorkin jusque-là brutalement c'est
devenu le diable qui sortait de sa boîte
et la molécule dramatique dangereux
c'est épouvantable ça c'est assez c'est
assez curieux c'est assez inexplicable
savez moi j'ai j'ai quelque chose qu une
petite anecdote qui va vous amuser je
suis de la région lorraine
et nous avions dans notre région le
docteur bastien le docteur bastien était
un médecin généraliste de campagne qui
avait remarqué qu' il y avait moyen de
guérir
les empoisonnements à l'amanite
phalloïde par un traitement très simple
de l'aspirine de la vitamine c est
quelque chose de 13,2 très simple il y a
fallu qu'il s'intoxiquent lui même trois
fois dont une fois devant le lan 7 pour
qu'on finisse par reconnaître que le
traitement qu'il avait proposé contre
l'intoxication à l'amanite phalloïde
était le bon alors vous savez moi je
suis habitué à voir des hommes étrangers
qui proposent des choses un petit peu
hors norme et je suis très intéressé par
ça c'est la curiosité même de la
médecine
à partir du moment où un médecin perd
toute curiosité toute capacité à aller
innover et rechercher des choses un
petit peu différente sortir des sentiers
battus ça n'est plus un médecin moi je
pense que le dr raul nous ramène à notre
à notre réalité de médecins et puis nous
de médecins de campagne et la dernière
remarque que j'aurai à faire très
rapidement c'est de vous dire que toutes
ces commission denquête sont
merveilleuses elles ne nous ont jamais
interrogés nous en tant que médecin de
campagne en tant que médecin de terrain
je n'ai pas entendu le moindre médecin
de campagne qui est donné son opinion
quant à l'évolution et au traitement de
cette crise et je trouve ça tout à fait
déplorable
jean paul hamon vous entendez un les
propos de thierry lardeux moi qu'est ce
que vous avez envie de répondre vous qui
voilà qui n'est pas vraiment pro hydroxy
chloroquine on sait que d'ailleurs vous
l'avez testé si je ne me trompe pas et
que ça ne vous a pas forcément bien
réussi ça vous a même rendu malade vous
comprenez quand même les propos tout
simplement même de dire et de bon sens
de votre confrère j'ai fait d'abord
répondre à thierry tu sais d'eux c'est
demain demain je vais à la commission
denquête à l'assemblée nationale et ne
t'inquiète pas qui rit même si clamart
n'est pas la campagne ils vont entendre
la voix d'un média clairin surveillance
d'après son agent paul sur la façon
lamentable dont klaus à cette affaire a
été gérée canton revenir pour revenir à
ligue roc cyclo rockin honnêtement moi
je demandais pas grand chose à rajouter
qu'ils fassent avec les moyens qu'il a
dans son institut qui fasse une étude en
double aveugle c'était pas trop
compliqué maintenant
maintenant il ya eu effectivement dans
l'est il ya eu beaucoup de médecins
généralistes quand contesté
l'azithromycine le zinc est là et
hydroxy chloroquine et ils ont constaté
que qu' il y avait moins
d'hospitalisations
donc effectivement bon alors c'est pas
une étude publiée dans le lancet tanfin
encore que maintenant lens est il a
quand même du plomb dans l aile après
l'étude qu'ils avaient qu'ils ont sortis
mais mais quand même on devrait on
devrait écouter les médecins terra
j'étais très surpris qu'on interdise
l'exercice la prescription de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine parce que les
médecins effectivement font pas
n'importe quoi il n'allait pas donner
l'hydroxyte le roecklin à quelqu'un qui
avait des troubles cardiaques
donc c'était pas faire courir un risque
aux patients que dû en faire comme lui
faire prendre de l'hydro de cyclos
rockin moi vous savez j'ai été comme
tout le monde
au bout de quatre jours j'en ai pris
pendant deux jours deux jours et demi
bon ggg pas supporter le traitement bon
parce que j'avais des nausées
bon vu le plus que des nausées âge je
mettais plein pied par terre
est-ce que c'était l'effet du virus est
ce que c'était l'effet de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine associé à les hydro mucine
j'en sais rien en tous les cas j'ai
arrêté au bout de deux jours et demi bon
voilà ça m'a pas empêché de faire un
épisode fébrile pendant trois jours qui
m'a fait tremper lit pendant trois jours
mais au 9e 10e et 11e jour mais mais
quand vous êtes atteints ou quand vous
avez dépassé en bas vous tester des
choses c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas de
poison c'est pas du poison qu'on donnait
cédric manche aaron docteur avec un s on
va écouter at série house lui évidemment
qui ne pensent pas comme vous jean paul
hamon bien au contraire écouter
professeurs le premier fut tentative
d'intoxication des esprits sur la
toxicité qui détermine et personne ne
dit que l'article qui nous tue encore
michael rend fou édictant des fous je ne
sais pas qui ça rend fou
en tout cas pas ceux qui parlent aussi
du rocking en revanche maintenant nous
avons toutes les études il ya eu une
censure
des journaux scientifiques tout à fait
une nuit
inédite est jamais arrivé mais on peut
pas empêcher la vérité de sortir depuis
elle finit toujours par sortir est la
tentative d'intoxication ce sont les
mots employés par le docteur house
thierry lardinoit vous vous partagez ce
diagnostic
quand même voilà qui laisse supposer que
voilà c'est très politique cette affaire
encore une fois c'est très compliqué
depuis le début nous - moi je dois bien
avouer que je comprends pas réellement
la motivation la motivation des choses
un médecin ça soigne et ça se préoccupe
pas de savoir si jamais on est dans les
clous exactement à partir du moment où
on ne fait pas plus de mal à son patient
que de ne rien faire
il vaut mieux faire cesser la moi c'est
ma c'est ma doctrine
moi j'ai soigné des patients non pas
avec de l'hydraulique urbaine puisque on
en avait parlé avec de l'asie trop
messine avec des résultats qui était
manifestement très positif donc
on aurait pu tout le moins s'interroger
s'organiser pour avancer sur ces voix là
et regardez qu'est ce qui fonctionnait
au lieu de terroriser la france sur des
sur des choses qui n'avaient pas
forcément lieu d'être
alors maintenant le débat de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine et de son efficacité cette
querelle professoral je sais pas si elle
profite aux français elle profite pas
forcément en français
bon maintenant le professeur raoul tu es
quelqu'un cas de forte conviction est qu
à bousculer les lignes c'est ça
peut-être l'intérêt des choses c'est de
bousculer les mines il s'est passé
positif d'avoir fait d'avoir c'est comme
ça va ça pour rien jusque devant on
pardonnez-moi va justement sortir de
france parce que depuis hier on sait que
le président brésilien se soigne à
l'hydroxyde chloroquine mais il a été
testé positif aux copies de 19 et puis
donald trump nous a refait une sortie 1
c'était hier vous propose de l'écouter
le très respecté henry ford il système
vient d'annoncer à partir d'un large
échantillon que l'hydroxyde chloroquine
a baissé de manière très significative
le taux de mortalité chez certains
patients malades les démocrates l'ont
écarté pour des raisons politiques mois
honteux agissez alors jean pas là non
non pas que toujours donald trump soit
très recommandable dans ses propos n'est
jamais un bol ce niveau mais tout de
même ce qui attire l'attention c'est
pourquoi ce gros débat en france alors
qu'il ya quand même
voilà les dirigeants ailleurs dans le
monde qui nous disent effectivement que
cette molécule est extrêmement efficace
on a du mal à comprendre
écoutez j'ai en matière de santé en
matière de santé publique je vais pas
trop écouté les recommandations comprend
foot qu'il miliana 10 elle voit la vie
celle de bolton à rosny celle de boy
sonore mais ils ont des médecins
vraiment autour de ses dirigeants
écoutez l'écouté et visiblement trop
humain d adhérer à des soucis avec le
docteur rossi qui est celui qui est la
tête de perfectionnement du pays donc
donc vous savez en matière de
recommandations scientifiques je ne
suivrai pas les recommandations du
docteur prince et les choses sont
claires
n'empêche il dit quelque chose
d'intéressant voilà il revient avec ce
côté politique est ce que justement vous
réfutez qu'ils puissent avoir tout
simplement un aspect politique derrière
ce débat qui est quand même assez
souvent houleux on a déjà vu d'ailleurs
sur ce plateau tient dit atterré
lardenois oui ben si oui effectivement
le dépasser 6 assez inexplicable jeu
franchement ces resserrements c'est
assez c'est assez inexplicable parce que
moi je considère que nous à dire tu es
très intéressant il semblerait qu'ils
recyclent leur quine réduisent la charge
virale donc son intérêt c'est de réduire
la charge virale dans les formes les
plus graves l'azithromycine lui étant
plus thérapeutique
donc franchement moi je suis très très
très intéressé par cette association
thérapeutique mais sur le plan pratique
pour soigner des gens en moi j'ai des
patients il rentre dans mon bureau il
sont malades ils veulent être guéris ils
ont de la famille ils ont des gens âgés
autour d'eux ils ont peur pour eux ils
veulent qu'on fasse quelque chose
moi j'ai voulu faire quelque chose et
très sincèrement j'ai tué personne avec
de la vitre en ligne mais j'ai vu
personne mourir decaux vite dans ma
patientèle donc je dois dire que je suis
un peu les part ça je me dis mon exemple
n'est pas forcément transférables parce
que c'est beaucoup trop petit comme
échantillon mais on aurait pu récupérer
interrogé il ya beaucoup de médecins de
moselle qui ont pratiqué un petit peu
comme comme j'ai pratiqué ou comme
différent conférant confrères en
pratique et on a immédiatement jeté la
vindicte sur eux au lieu d'aller les
interroger leur dire mais comment
comment vous faites qu'est ce qui se
passe qu'est ce que vous en pensez
qu'est ce que vous constatez voilà on
est toujours dans ce pays dans la même
façon de penser est une façon de
pantalons ans est centralisé qui vient
d'en haut on nous dit vous devez faire
comme ça et les gens qui sont en bas de
l'échelle
je suis un ouvrier de la médecine je
suis un ouvrier de la médecine chez un
médecin généraliste de campagne s'il est
un ouvrier de la médecine
eh ben on n'a pas le droit de cité mais
il faut savoir que l'ouvrier de la
médecine c'est comme l'ouvrier d'une
chaîne quand sur la chaîne il tombe en
panne ici que le boulon qui à deux
millimètres de trop si le leem un petit
peu ça va mieux marché eh bien nous
aussi on sait que quand on fait le mans
médicaments bon moment ça va mieux
marcher au juste passer le temps de nous
écouter et de nous de prendre ce temps
tu sais tout mais c'est ce qui serait
pas dans ce pays j'en parlais moment le
mot de la fin
c'est vrai c'est vrai que beaucoup de
généralistes y compris moi quand j'ai
refait boulot après avoir été arrêté à
temps on a prescrit des macrolides dont
l'azithromycine fait partie on l'a on a
prescrit des macrolides sans aucune
recommandation on n'a pas pu prescrire
les gros trip la rouquine parce que bon
on était on était interdit de prescrire
mais mais c'est vrai que
systématiquement devant des gens qui
présentait de symptômes de covile et moi
j'en ai vu certainement moins que toi
dans ton coin parce que vous vous avez
eu un sacré paquet de 2k bon mais on va
pas faire d'études sur le pod cas qu'on
a vu et pour lesquelles on l'a donnée
souad azithromycine soit soit l'un des
rites romy sin ou un autre macrolides
merci à tous les deux jean paul hamon
série l'art de noix d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france pour ce
débat merci à vous et un mot sur le
ségur de la santé le chef de l'exécutif
a créé la surprise il annoncé hier une
rallonge on en parlait de plus d'un
milliard d'euros à l'enveloppé consacrée
aux personnels hospitaliers les
discussions se sont donc poursuivis
aujourd'hui avec les syndicats avec ce
nouvel élément des syndicats qui
accusent le gouvernement d'avoir failli
sur un sujet délicat la reconnaissance
du coville 19 comme maladie
professionnelle lorsqu'elle a été
contractée dans le cadre du travail
[Musique]
[Rires]
on se gargarise de grandfonds flon à
propos des soignants mais dès qu'il
s'agit de passer aux travaux pratiques
les mesures ne suivent pas on est loin
d'une reconnaissance automatique pour
les soignants y compris pour des
séquelles qui pourraient survenir demain
[Musique]
restez avec nous donc quelques instants
nous parlerons de la décision officielle
des etats-unis de quitter l'om est ce un
coup dur pour l'organisation puisque le
budget américain représente 15% de son
budget global
et puis direction la chine qui s'est
dite prête à rejoindre les discussions
américano russes sur la réduction des
armes nucléaires
[Musique]
oh
une trump est vraiment passé à côté du
problème dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences cessent selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il ya une impunité assumer il y a une
culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
jamais
[Musique]
vous maintenez le traitement à base
d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie trône
ici malgré la polémique mondiale sur
l'efficacité de cette combinaison
d'erreurs nous avions déjà commencé à
utiliser le protocole avec les boutiques
préoccupe bien avant que le match ne
commence son essai par sénégal la
chloroquine de manière à les utiliser
pendant des décennies et des décennies
ça pourrait faire sourire les c'est la
galère quand j'entends je dis non il n'y
a pas de signes qui m'est rendu
oui mais voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons on est dans une
espèce de déni collectif on ne veut pas
croire ce qu'on sait et scientifique
parle quand même de la sixième
extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction et la vie sur terre à
d'autres experts qui contestent nos
résidents de six personnes
non non c'est pas vrai il ya des climats
tous et non ce n'est pas rien à part il
ya des gens qui ne sont pas des
chercheurs qui parlent que la presse met
en avant parce que il faut que du débat
le gars plus de débats aujourd'hui il
n'y a plus aucun débat ce changement
climatique et on va faire un prêt par
une catastrophe ou 20 vers une vraie
catastrophe et on est incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimiste tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et les demis y en
n'a pas d'ennemi l'ennemi ceni
[Musique]
je
le fait que nous avons eu ce problème de
la pandémie qui a été mondiale va amener
d'autres façons de faire des affaires et
les choses dont beaucoup se concentrer
sur l'humain et sur l'environnement
partout en afrique les présidents
prennent conscience qu'il faut vraiment
se réindustrialiser et là je pense que
l'aco vie va permettre à cette ré
industrialisation cela ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne doit plus commercer mais
remercié de manière différents qui
permettent à tout un chacun d'avoir un
travail décent un salaire décent
je pense que le salaire qui permet de
vivre ça c'est le plus encore
[Musique]
oui
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre elle les musées avec trois mois
de non activité où les billetteries sont
à l'arrêt l'impact financier est énorme
ce sera un rare démarche sous conditions
1 avec port du masque obligatoire
distanciation physique gestion des flux
de ce que nous attendons c'est
effectivement la possibilité de rouvrir
sans ces mesures barrières le plus vite
possible
on retrouvera pas le marché que nous
avons quitté en 2021
il faudra reconstruire le marché s'y
reprendre à plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france 20h30
heure de paris une menace qui n'en est
plus une ces faits les états unis
entament leur retrait de l' oms
un retrait qui sera effective dans un an
et qui marque un revers de la
coopération internationale selon le
gouvernement allemand
on le rappelle donald trump reprochent à
l'organisation mondiale de la santé une
gestion trop tardive de la crise du
coronavirus le candidat démocrate à la
maison blanche joe biden a aussitôt
réagi coûte
les américains sont plus en sécurité
quand l'amérique s'engage pour renforcer
la santé mondiale
le premier jour de ma présidence je
rejoindre l oms et réaffirmé notre
leadership mondial
pour en parler nous sommes en direct de
standford avec allen or avocat c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir à la non merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors comment
cette décision surprenante de donald
trump est elle perçue aux états unis
bonjour je ne pense pas que le président
ait choqué surpris que ce soit car il
avait déjà annoncé cette décision il
faut un an avant le retrait donc
beaucoup de personnes espèrent quand en
novembre un changement empêchera cela
alors évidemment pas surprenant ça
faisait un petit moment qu'il y avait
des tensions entre l' oms et donald
trump
il ya les arguments officiels indulgent
se montrait vis-à-vis de la chine la
gestion du coc vide
on imagine aussi une arrière pensée
politique de la part du président
américain en campagne et s'est
complètement
je ne suis pas le mieux placé pour juger
ce qui se passe concernant ce virus
mondial et les actions de l'om est ce
parce que les états unis n'ont pas réagi
avant fin janvier et ne fit toujours pas
toutes les consignes émises par l'om est
c'est pour cela sans doute qu'il ya
beaucoup de patients souffrant du la
cofidis neufs aux états unis donc il est
difficile de juger le ms c'est
effectivement donc très politique
politique aussi parce que donald trump
justement protéger les états unis on
sait que voilà ce budget c'est 15%
là le budget américain 15% du budget de
l'eau msa dit quelque chose ça veut dire
voilà on reste entre nous on se protège
et on va plus vers la collectivité
ce n'est pas la raison de l'existence de
lohan s on ne peut pas se protéger sans
en faire partie parce que si l'on ne
faisait pas partie alors il aurait été
moins informés de cette crise cela fait
au moins vingt ans que nous sommes au
sein de l' oms et donc cela ne consiste
pas simplement à quitter le ms avec
l'autre carte bancaire le virus se
déplace dans le monde sans le ms loi
mais c est une nécessité et nous ne
devrions pas en ce moment quitter l'om
est ce cela fait partie effectivement
d'une idée selon laquelle les etats-unis
doivent s'occuper d'eux mêmes mais ce
n'est pas un bon plan alors c'est vrai
que l'on aimait ça a été quand même
critiqué dans la gestion de sa crise a
commis quelques erreurs notamment voilà
sur les conseils sur le masque au départ
est-ce que quand même
voilà cette organisation devrait
peut-être aussi se remettre en cause et
donald trump agite un petit peu je puis
me permettre cette expression familière
le cocotier en se retirant de
l'institution on n'est pas le messie
c'est un c'est un travail d'équipé
le président obama avant donald trump
avait averti des pandémies à venir que
donc effectivement nous aurions pu agir
mais nous ne l'avons pas fait et je
pense que faire cavalier seul mais
heureux dieu résoudra pas la situation
loi metz a commis des erreurs mais
suivre plutôt quitté la table ce n'est
pas une bonne solution solution car l'om
s est vrai pour le bien-être du monde et
les spasmes ils font partie du monde
donc effectivement il ya eu des erreurs
mais cela ne signifie pas qu'il faut
partir
quelles conséquences selon vous à la
naure ce retrait peut-il avoir dans les
relations extérieures américaine une
fois de plus nous quittons la table
mondial des négociations et nous
replions sur tout bénéficiant de moins
d'informations nous ne sommes plus aussi
impliquées et nous ne pouvons plus
partager des informations avec par
exemple ou ms effectivement il ya eu des
mauvaises informations concernant les
masques mais notre centre de contrôle
des maladies et notre état continue à
répandre des messages qui ne sont pas
parfaitement correcte concernant
l'utilisation des masques donc il ne
faut pas essayer de trouver des
coupables
ce n'est pas une bonne idée sachant que
les états unis ne gère pas très bien la
situation de quitter l'om s nous ne
suivons pas les procédures de l'om
est-ce alors joe biden adversaire
démocrate de donald trump à la
présidentielle
ge a prévenu que s'il était élu le 3
novembre prochain il annulerait ce
retrait est ce que cette décision de
l'actuel donc le candidat démocrate peut
peser dans la balance électorale
oui je pense effectivement que cette
décision pèsera concernant la position
des états unis au niveau mondial
l'argent que nous donnions à l' oms nous
donnait également beaucoup d'influx ans
je pense effectivement que la question
sera les etats-unis vont-ils devenir un
pays isolationniste où vont ils
continuer à contribuer à l'économie et
aux affaires mondiales
merci à la naure d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir la chine pose ses
conditions pour prendre part aux
négociations sur la suite du traité new
start il s'agit d'un accord russo
américain sur les armes nucléaires pékin
se dit désormais disposé à discuter si
washington réduit son arsenal ou si la
chine augmentent le sien pékin prête
donc à discuter si et seulement si
américains et chinois dispose du même
armement nucléaire et la main medjahed
la chine s'est dite prête ce mercredi à
se joindre aux négociations trilatérales
sur la prolongation du traité new start
une condition imposée et pas des
moindres pékin veut obtenir avant la
parité des arsenaux nucléaires avec les
états unis et la russie
sans ça les autorités chinoises
considèrent n'avoir aucun intérêt à se
mettre autour de la table
anne fordham afghanes pour les états
unis demandaient à la chine de
participer aux négociations dit
trilatérale n'est rien d'autre qu'un
stratagème pour détourner l'attention du
monde pour déplacer les responsabilités
et pour créer un prétexte leur
permettant de s'éloigner du new star
comment on fait pour de nombreuses
autres crises et de contrôle des
armements vis-à-vis de la presse
la priorité pour nous je le répète et
que les états unis et la russie accepte
de trop
auger le nouveau traité start et sur
cette base nous espérons que les états
unis et la fédération de russie
continuerons à réduire leur arsenal
nucléaire afin que la chine y
participent lorsque leur arsenal
nucléaire sera ramené à un niveau
comparable à celui des ogives nucléaires
chinoises tendent à toi là mon propos
la chine semble toujours faire de la
résistance aux invitations de washington
le mois dernier à vienne les états unis
et la russie ont repris les pourparlers
sur le contrôle des armes nucléaires
stratégiques pékin conviés à ce rendez
vous n'a pas fait le déplacement
une absence dénoncé alors par
l'émissaire américain nous avons
clairement fait savoir à la chine que
nous attendons d'elles qu'elles honorent
concrètement son obligation de négocier
avec nous de bonne foi dans le cadre du
traité de non-prolifération
elle s'est engagée sur une voie qui mène
droit dans le mur
même si le débat reste vif sur la place
de la chine le dialogue devrait se
poursuivre au cours de l'été le temps
presse puisque l'accord new start signé
il ya dix ans entre les etats-unis et la
russie expire dans sept mois
ce traité de réduction des armements a
permis jusque là de limiter à 700 le
nombre de lanceurs nucléaires
stratégiques et à 1550 le nombre de
têtes nucléaires déployées sur ces
lanceurs le traité ne concerne pas les
armes nucléaires tactiques de moindre
portée et ne limite pas le stocks
d'ogives nucléaires inactive
en 2020 les américains et les russes en
dispose de près de 6000 contre seulement
320 pour les chinois new start c'est le
dernier accord de contrôle des armements
entre washington et moscou encore en
vigueur
le président américain donald trump a
déjà écarté les etats-unis 2-3 traités
internationaux de désarmement dernier
retrait en date l'accord ciel ouvert qui
lie et 35 pays et assurer des
possibilités réciproque de surveillance
aérienne
pour en parler nous sommes avec claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales en direct de notre
studio de caumartin est bon soir que
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
alors avant de parler un des
déclarations de la chine un mot si vous
voulez bien sur le traité start sur la
réduction des armes nucléaires accord
américano russes dont on négocie la
prolongation et quelle est la stratégie
américaine dans ce dossier pour aboutir
un new start
évidemment comme les chiffres que vous
venez de donner le montre bien
90% des armes nucléaires sont
actuellement détenus par les américains
et par les russes donc il est très
important que les américains et les
russes se mettent d'accord pour
renouveler le traité start qui prévoit
en effet des plafonds pour les fusées
stratégiques et pour les ogives
nucléaires qui sont assujettis
d'ailleurs dans une rue dans cette
parité se transcrit dans un parité
global nucléaire entre les etats-unis et
la russie
puisqu'on a cité tout à l'heure le
chiffre de 6000 ogives nucléaires
de part et d'autre toutes ne sont pas
actives certaines sont sur étagère mais
il y à une relative parité est en effet
c'est ça qui compte et c'est la raison
pour laquelle la russie souhaite le
renouvellement la reconduction de cet
accord alors il ya une incertitude en
effet sur la volonté de washington
puisque washington depuis plusieurs
années des noms successivement tous les
traités qui relève les traités
bilatéraux avec la russie qui relèvent
de ce qu'on avait appelé larmes ce
contrôle le contrôle des armements et le
dernier en date c'est le traité sur les
forces nucléaires intermédiaires qui a
été dénoncé l'année dernière et qui
concerne les missiles de croisière et
les fusées dont la portée est un terme
et d intermédiaire entre 500 et 5500 km
en gros sel qui tomberait sur nos têtes
en europe
donc nous sommes les premiers concernés
ce traité n'existe plus puisque les
américains en sont sortis et que par
conséquent naturellement les russes
aussi puisque c'était un traité
bilatéral est ce qu'il se passera la
même chose
le 5 février prochain
pour le traité new star c'est bien
possible c'est même très vraisemblable
parce que l'attitude américaine que
monsieur bolton avant qu'ils soient
remerciés d'ailleurs par monsieur trump
avait été exposée lui-même à poutine
l'année dernière c'est que ce traité
start est dépassé il est obsolète
puisque il ne tient pas compte d'un
certain nombre de nouveaux armements et
surtout de l'émergence de la chine
or la chine jusqu'à présent sont détenus
à un minimum un stock minimum pour cette
dissuasion nucléaire c'est-à-dire 324
nucléaire la france et 290 et on
considère habituellement que autour de
300 c'est le seuil de crédibilité de la
dissuasion nucléaire est évidemment la
chine répond de la même façon
tactiquement on en reparlera lorsque les
niveaux convergeront alors ça veut dire
qu'elle a l'intention en effet
d'accroître le nombre d'ogives
nucléaires qu'elle détient et qu'elle
s'attend à ce que le nouveau nouveau
start qui pourrait être négociée entre
les etats-unis et la russie d'ici le
mois de février qu on se consacrerait
une réduction des stocks d'ogives
américaines et russes et des fusées qui
permettent de les envoyer de les
délivrer
c'est évidemment parfaitement illusoire
et donc le vrai sujet c'est est ce que
le président qui sera en charge au mois
de janvier prochain à washington
considéra que l'intérêt des états unis
c'est de renouveler ce traité ou bien
est ce que monsieur trump qui sera peut
être réélu ou qui aura peut-être
dénoncer le traité start
auparavant considérera il vaut mieux
sans se livrer à une course aux
armements puisque les états unis sont là
puis cela la puissance économique la
plus importante du monde
effectivement dans une compétition dans
une course aux armements et bien les
etats-unis considèrent qu'il pourrait
bien gagner
quel est l'intérêt pour les états unis
de mêlée pékin en négociations et en
posant cette condition qu espère
réellement
pékin de son côté alors pour les
américains c'est purement tactique en
effet puisqu'ils savent très bien que
pékin n'acceptera pas que pékin
considère que c'est une affaire
bilatérale au niveau où se situent les
stocks américains et les stocks russes
c'est à ces deux pays de fixer les la
réduction et qu' on en reparlera en
effet lorsque ce niveau sera comparable
au niveau au niveau chinois ça veut dire
dans très longtemps donc c'est une
utilisation tactique de la chine et pour
la chine
elle est assez embarrassé pour répondre
bien entendu puisque elle est une
puissance nucléaire militaire connue par
le traité de non prolifération comme
d'ailleurs la france et la
grande-bretagne et qu'elle considère qu'
elle a le droit d'avoir un stock encore
une fois crédible de dissuasion
nucléaire merci à claude blanchemaison
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir apporté
votre analyse
le président libanais michel aoun a reçu
l'ambassadrice américaine cet après midi
est venu accompagné du commandant des
opérations militaires des etats-unis au
moyen-orient
lors de cette rencontre le général mc
kenzie a souligné je cite l'importance
du partenariat solide entre les états
unis et l'armée libanaise michel aoun
pour sa part appelé à améliorer la
coopération militaire entre les deux
pays
et cette visite a suscité la colère des
libanais proche du hezbollah
ce matin ils ont organisé un
rassemblement sur la route de l'aéroport
de beyrouth
ils accusent le général mc kenzie et de
s'être rendu au liban pour commémorer
l'attentât d' octobre 1983
une attaque qui avait coûté la vie à
deux cent vingt marins américains et qui
avait été revendiqué par l'organisation
du jihad islamique affiliées au
hezbollah écouter ces manifestants c'est
vrai que nous faisons face à un blocus
économique mais c'est impossible
d'instaurer un blocus contre notre
dignité nous pourrons toujours avoir des
positions honorables contre eux ce à
quoi ils ne sont pas habitués
nous pouvons toujours leur envoyer des
restes et des corps dans les cercueils
nous voulons dire à l'américain qu'il
n'a pas le droit de venir au liban
il n'a pas le droit de commémorer ces
dates insolente les américains nous ont
affamé et ont fait de nous des sans abri
les nous assiège toujours et nous
affament ils ont aidé l'ennemi sioniste
à nous frapper au fil des années et
sachez qu'un conseiller du chef de
l'agent spécial russe a été arrêté pour
trahison
ils s'appellent eux ivan safronov il
était auparavant j'en ai dit spécialiste
des questions militaires et spatiales
pourquoi at il été arrêté qu est ce qu
on lui reproche exactement que
risque-t-il ont fait le point avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine clairon
c'est la surprise et les mois du côté de
ceux qui connaissent ivan safronov
d'autant que d'après son employeur
l'agencé spatiale russe roskosmos son
arrestation n'est pas lié à son emploi
actuel est d'après le porte-parole du
kremlin
elle n'est pas liée non plus à ses
précédentes enquêtes du temps où il
était encore journaliste
quoi qu'il en soit dimitri peskov a fait
savoir qu'il fallait mettre de côté les
émotions et laisser travailler la
justice
nous avons lu de nombreux articles
publiés à ce sujet mais tous ces
articles journalistiques sont
principalement basées sur des émotions
il est évident qu'ils ne contiennent pas
et ne peuvent pas contenir des
informations réelles sur les résultats
du travail du service de contre
espionnage
c'est très simple cette affaire doit
être examiné par le tribunal
il y à une accusation il y a les
résultats du travail des services
spéciaux la décision sera prise par le
tribunal de 2010 à 2019 ivan safronov
était journaliste au sein de la
rédaction du quotidien économique russe
kommersant où il était spécialisé dans
les domaines de la coopération militaire
ou encore dans le spatial et le fsb le
soupçonne donc d'avoir transmis d'avoir
livré des informations aux services
secrets tchèque entre 2012 et 2017 des
informations en lien avec des livraisons
d'armes russes au moyen-orient et dans
plusieurs pays d'afrique
en conséquence ils vont de safran
l'homme a été placé en détention
provisoire pour une durée de deux mois
et risque jusqu'à 20 ans de prison
son avocat pour sa part regrette ces
accusations à l'encontre de son client
et entend bien faire appel de cette
décision de justice en tant que partie
de la défense nous considérons la
décision prise aujourd'hui par le
tribunal de district de l'est photo rv
au comme illégale et infondée
il est évident ils feront appel dans les
délais fixés par la loi
mais pour le moment l'enquète
préliminaire est en cours
l'enquète durera très probablement aussi
longtemps qu'habituellement
quand il s'agit de telles affaires donc
personne ne s'est précipité ensuite
étant donné qu'il s'agit d'informations
constitue un secret d'état
je le répète encore une fois c'est ce
qu'affirme et enquête alors on s'attend
à ce que le procès se déroulent
également à huis clos
parmi ses ex collègues on s'étonne aussi
de ces accusations il a reçu de nombreux
soutiens via les réseaux sociaux
notamment mais aussi via un
rassemblement qui s'est déroulé dans la
journée de mardi en plein centre de
moscou et à l'issue duquel plusieurs
arrestations
eu lieu place maintenant à l'instruction
de cette affaire dont les médias
n'auront hélas pas grand accès en raison
du caractère sensible classé secret
d'état de cette affaire dans quelques
instants rester avec nous nous parlerons
des suppressions de postes de la filière
française de nokia plus de 2200 postes
concernés puis nous analyserons les
premières déclarations du nouveau
premier ministre jean castex qui annonce
une crise sans précédent ça sera l'objet
de notre face à face tout à l'heure
[Musique]
le fait que nous avons eu ce problème de
la pandémie qui a été mondiale va amener
d'autres façons de faire des affaires et
les choses vont beaucoup se concentrer
sur l'humain et sur l'environnement
partout en afrique les présidents
prennent conscience qu'il faut vraiment
se réindustrialiser et là je pense que
l'aco vie va permettre à cette région
industrielle isation cela ne veut pas
dire qu'on ne doit plus commercer mais
commercer de manière différents qui
permettent à tout un chacun d'avoir un
travail décent un salaire décent
je pense que le salaire qui permet le
vivre ça c'est le plus encore
[Musique]
pour air france pour renault ce sont des
entreprises qui seront je dirais en fête
permanente
on va obliger les entreprises un
contexte actuel à garder leurs salariés
ça n'a pas de sens parce que ça fait
longtemps que je soutiens une des
nombreuses garanties
c'est dire on propose un emploi toutes
ces personnes en attendant qu'elles
retrouvent un autre jeune dont on n'a
aucune vision aucune
et ça c'est malheureusement dans tous
les domaines au lieu de dépenser des
milliards comme ça pour rien il faudrait
mieux les dépensés pour former les gens
et les replacer ailleurs
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons on est dans une
espèce de déni collectif on ne veut pas
croire ce qu'on sait et scientifique
parle quand même de la sixième
extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
y'a d'autres experts qui contestent leur
usine en russie
personne non non c'est pas vrai il ya
des climats tous et non ce n'est pas il
y en a pas il ya des gens qui ne sont
pas des chercheurs qui parlent que la
presse met en avant parce que il faut
que du débat le ya plus de débat
aujourd'hui
y a plus aucun débat ce changement
climatique et on va faire un vrai par
une catastrophe ou 20 vers une vraie
catastrophe et on est incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas de pessimiste tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et l'ennemi y'en a
pas d'ennemis l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encourage la fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fonds pouvant remettre en cause la
pensée des groupes de pression voire
l'étude démontre la nocivité de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine au nom de la
peur de la mort
notre ministre a interdit immédiatement
son utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société sacs
tissent dont certains les employés ont
des qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique
les technocrates les activistes et de
nombreux journalistes ne s'intéressent
qu'à la partie qui va dans leur sens et
censure ou dévalorise le reste on décide
de ce que le peuple doit penser
[Musique]
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi deux de profession est
ce qui explique cette énergie que vous
mettez cet engagement critiques contre
le féminisme actuelle je pense que un
modèle de société est à bout de souffle
et que nous avons en effet besoin de
repenser le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons
quels rapports vont nous devons
instaurer aux êtres et aux choses
on s'oriente quoi dire une société très
puritaine oui puritaine au sens où le
désir et et criminaliser le fait que
l'homme soit sensible aux charmes
féminins et rendu suspect
[Musique]
nous recevons pauline d'orgeval
présidente et cofondatrice de kohat
petit santé le pratiquent même de notre
association c'est de réduire les
inégalités d'accès à la santé et d'accès
aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis fini
par renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck fallu que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
près de six mois de comprendre ce qui se
passe tout l'enjeu de notre association
c'est construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
vous maintenez le traitement à base
d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie trop mis
6 malgré la polémique mondiale sur
l'efficacité de cette combinaison le
porte parole
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les deux types préoccupe
bien avant que le match ne commence à
sonner chez par sénégal la chloroquine
domaniale est utilisé pendant des
décennies et des décennies ça pourrait
faire sourire les sénégalais quand
j'entends de niche des ménages
il n'y a pas de signes qui montrent en
outre supporter
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans sa
cuisine des bâches me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'ils
avaient une équipe de 25 usines et
autour pour nous pour nos fournisseurs
pour nos équipes c'était essentiel
d'ouvrir le plus tôt possible
beaucoup disent que la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le groupe d'avants
il était formidable et qu'on a envie de
le retrouver
on sait que ça allait me rendre plus
tolérante et ça m'a rendu plus à
talairan alors par mois elle s'était
imposée justement délirer autour d'un
dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche n'a pas
le bac
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tony que le mental
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission il est
21h heure de paris tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi
8 juillet des plans sociaux en pleine
crise économique ça ne passe pas du côté
des salariés de manifestations se sont
tenues aujourd'hui à paris un
rassemblement des employés de nokia d'un
côté de sanofi de l'autre ils prévoient
chacun supprimer plus de 1000 postes en
france
manifestations également aux provinces
pour les salariés d'airbus et d'europe
un gouvernement de combat et des
territoires les mots du premier ministre
jean castex devant les députés ce matin
une nouvelle ligne qui se veut plus
proche de la population mais qui suscite
des interrogations sur l'orientation
économique de l'exécutif
est ce la fin de la start up nation nous
en débattons l'australie à leur dure
confinement 5 millions de personnes sont
à nouveau astreinte à résidence à
melbourne deuxième plus grande ville du
pays depuis hier soir une mesure pour
faire face à une flambée de
contamination de coronavirus depuis le
début de la pandémie l'australien
enregistré près de 9000 cas et plus de
100 décès le royaume uni reprend à la
vente d'armes à l'arabie saoudite ces
transactions avaient été suspendues l'an
dernier par décision de justice
en cause la crainte de l'utilisation de
ce matériel militaire dans des crimes de
guerre au yémen
hier la secrétaire d'état au commerce
international britannique et a affirmé
qu'il ne s'agissait que d' acte isolé
[Musique]
et
plusieurs manifestations en france
aujourd'hui des milliers de salariés
d'airbus à toulouse et d'europe à
morlaix dans le nord à paris et sané de
sanofi cette fois et ceux de nokia ont
manifesté aussi tous pour exprimer leur
colère contre les suppressions d'emplois
chez nokia 1200 emplois en france sont
concernées aient déjà il y a quelques
jours une manifestation autour du site
de lannion en bretagne avait rassemblé
près de 5000 personnes pour l'en titre
elle se fait taire cfdt nokia un
reproche à l'entreprise veut ne pas
tenir ses promesses
ok avait promis de préserver le niveau
d'emploi et d'augmenter le nombre
d'emplois en r&d l'augmenter de 500 nets
de passer de 2000 à 2500 il se trouve
que ils ont toujours joué avec cet
engagement ils n'ont pas tenu totalement
on n'a jamais atteint des 2500 et on a
appris récemment que dès 2018 il avait
prévu de licencier et de supprimer une
grande partie de la r&d en france donc
tout en embauchant des salariés nouveau
des jeunes à lannion à nausée en région
parisienne il préparait le plan de
licenciement pour les renvoyer à la fin
des engagements qu'ils avaient pris un
coup au gouvernement français le
gouvernement français se sent trahi les
salariés encore pire évidemment et on
fragilise énormément la r&d en france la
recherche et développement
une manifestation suivie par notre
reporter katia technique écouter ces
précisions
c'est la deuxième journée de
mobilisation pour les salariés de nokia
certains sont venus de lannion dans les
côtes d'armor à paris montparnasse ce
matin et se sont dirigés ensuite vers
les invalides avant d'atteindre
l'ambassade de finlande mais chemin
faisant ils ont rencontre
et les salariés en détresse de sanofi
qui la rend prêter à leurs moyens
techniques alors quelques centaines de
personnes ici ainsi que des élus
politiques des figures syndicale
pourquoi sont-ils regrouper bien pour se
poser en quatrième plan social de nokia
qui comptent se débarrasser de mille
deux cent trente trois personnes
il y à des personnes visées donc dans la
r&d principalement dans les sites de
lannion dans les côtes d'armor est
également nausée en essonne les salariés
demandent une annulation pure et simple
du plan social je me reposais les
écouter moi je suis touché parce qu'en
fait dans mon équipe on est on est
centre ans en ait 200 et sur les deux
sens et à 139 personnes qui doivent
partir on a été félicité pendant la
période de confinement nous en féliciter
de notre rendement nous a dit qu'ils
étaient satisfaits et tous n'ont pas
compris ce qui s'est passé juste donc ça
n'a rien à voir avec le vide parce que
le secteur des télécoms se porte très
bien
quatre ans après le rachat d'alcatel par
nokia et les engagements de maintenir
l'emploi et bien quatre ans après c'est
quasiment la fermeture annoncée du site
de lannion des élus et patrons de
syndicats sont venus soutenir les
salariés aujourd'hui je reposte de les
écouter
le problème général nous avons répondu
que mon ombre le gouvernement des plots
de car j'en ai quatre sans suite
en face à la crise en parallèle de cette
entreprise micro et des sorties de
l'huile et nous disons que ça public
pour servir à maintenir les
pouvoir a relocalisé d'industrie or
c'est tout l'inversé nokia est en train
de jouer comme des pétroliers parfois je
vous convie à une marée noire
il est en train de déverser ses cuves
pour partie faire prendre en croyant que
ça allait se passer inaperçu ça ne
passera pas inaperçue la cfdt de cette
affaire l'une des premières
organisations dans cette entreprise
on va le mettre au pied du mur on va
essayer décoller au maximum contre le
mur on leur dira vous devez rendre des
comptes les syndicats s'étonnent puisque
cinq milliards ont été versés en
dividendes aux actionnaires depuis 2016
et puis à l'entreprise nokia a reçu des
crédits d'état alors pourquoi licenciés
aujourd'hui pour une f1 il s'agit tout
simplement d'un plan de rationalisation
pour accroître sa compétitivité sa
rentabilité mais il faut dire qu'à
l'époque du rachat d' alcatel-lucent 1
dont sont issus les deux sites dont je
parlais et bien la vente avait été
monitorer par par bercy par emmanuel
macron lui-même pour sauvegarder
l'emploi
aujourd'hui bercy a demandé au géant
finlandais de revoir sa copie pour les
syndicats et pour les salariés c'est net
ils ne veulent aucun licenciement
et pour en parler et christian
saint-etienne économistes bonsoir
christian
c'est d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france les salariés de ces deux
entreprises dénoncent des suppressions
de postes abusive
est-ce qu'ils ont raison bien sûr c'est
plus qu'un fusil c'est scandaleux
d'abord il ya une erreur stratégique
majeure de livrer alcatel à nokia
c'est une abc dit et stratégiques c'est
une erreur qui a été commise ya quatre
ans en contrepartie nokia avait pris des
engagements extrêmement strictes donc
l'état français doit réagir y compris en
attaquant nokia devant les tribunaux
internationaux et en exigeant des
dommages punitifs
c'est ce que le comportement de nokia
est totalement inacceptable je pense
qu'il serait même utile que l'état
français fasse un raid contre cette
entreprise pour racheter son capital il
faut que la france réagisse face à ce
coup de force
alors effectivement le plan de nokia est
jugé inacceptable en l'état en tout cas
par la ministre délégué à l'industrie en
espagne et ruina chez mémé concrètement
quand même christian saint-pierre l'état
peut-il sanaa au pardon excusez moi oui
effectivement
est-ce que l'étape vraiment intervenir
christian saint-etienne oui on pourrait
même imaginer qu'il y ait une
nationalisation de ce qui reste en
france mais le plus utile c'est ce que
j'évoquais ça serait une prise de
participation y compris en allant au
clash avec la finlande
voilà entre pays européens on ne peut
pas avoir des comportements de ce type
sachant que par ailleurs les les plans
sociaux de cette nature vont se
multiplier mais des plans sociaux qui
sont liées à une adaptation de la main
d'oeuvre dans un contexte de baisse de
la demande c'est une chose mais nokia
est dans un secteur en très forte
progression
donc tout ce qui est numérique
informatique est en explosion au plan
international donc il n'y a aucune
raison que la france laisse passer il
faut prendre des mesures
extrêmement dur sur ce sujet puisqu'il y
avait des engagements de cette
entreprise les syndicats exigent tout
cas de l'état qu'il réclame le
remboursement du crédit d'impôt à louer
à nokia 280 millions d'euros quand même
c'est possible justement un de les
récupérer
je disais tout à l'heure il faut
attaquer nokia devant les tribunaux non
seulement il faut exiger le
remboursement de du crédit impôt
recherche mais il faut demander des
dommages punitifs de dix fois la somme
c'est à dire il faut demander 2 8
milliards de dommages punitifs
dans la mesure où cette entreprise ne
respecte pas son contrat avec l'état
français
on est dans un moment il faut bien
comprendre que nous sommes dans le monde
a changé il ya dix ans et il nous sommes
dans un conflit pour la domination
stratégique mondial entre la chine et
les états unis avec un certain nombre
d'autres pays qui mènent des politiques
stratégiques extrêmement offensive comme
la russie le brésil l'inde l'allemagne
donc la france ne peut pas être le seul
pays qui ne fait pas respecter ses
intérêts qu'il ne fait pas respecter les
engagements qui ont été pris par des
entreprises vis-à-vis de l'état français
donc il faut que la france cesse de se
ridiculiser sur un certain nombre de
dossiers dont celui ci est donc toutes
les mesures doivent être prises comme
celle que j'ai évoquées à la fois
éventuellement une nationalisation
partielle des activités de nokia en
france y compris les activités de nokia
qui n'était pas venue d'alcatel
il faut également envisager d une action
stratégique extrêmement dur comme entre
nokia dans le cadre du développement de
la 5g pour imaginer une éviction de
nokia du marché français sur la 5g voilà
il faut être
il faut être extrêmement déterminé ce
que ne sont pas évidemment tout le monde
a compris les autorités françaises qui
vont une fois de plus se faire traîner
dans la farine et donc la france va une
fois de plus malheureusement se
ridiculiser vraisemblablement sur ce
dossier sachant que
oui la france a des moyens pour réagir
donc on va juger s'il est tard les
utilisent justement la question quand on
vous écoute on se demande à quoi
attribuer ce comportement
voilà très peu impliqué très peu
déterminé et combatif de la france il ya
plusieurs dossiers sur lesquels dans
l'est dans les dernières années la
france n'a pas défendu ses intérêts donc
tous les acteurs internationaux ont noté
ça il faut comprendre que vous avez si
vous voulez avoir une réflexion
stratégique sur le monde aujourd'hui
vous avez à peu près une trentaine
d'états dans le monde qui font 80 % du
pib mondial et vous avez au plan mondial
trente mille entreprises
trente mille groupes internationaux qui
font le tiers du pib mondial et les deux
tiers du commerce international et des
investissements internationaux
donc c'est un nombre très limité
d'acteurs une trentaine d'acteurs
étatiques 30000 grands groupes dont
quand un pays comme la france qui est un
pays majeur ne défend pas ses intérêts
vous pensez bien que les 30 états qui
mènent des politiques stratégiques voit
bien que la france ne défend pas les
intérêts et les 30000 groupes se disent
c'est un pays sur lequel on peut marcher
comme un tapis et s'essuyer les pieds
donc si la france ne réagit pas sur ce
dossier il y aura beaucoup d'autres
épisodes de ce type d'autres entreprises
quand elles internationale quand elles
seront des ajustements à faire
frapperont la france puisque d'autres
pays puisque ils se diront bas la france
n'ayant pas réagi sur des dossiers
précédents ne réagira pas à l'avenir
alors là c'est la conjonction de deux de
deux dossiers qui sont clés 1
on l'a déjà dit mais on le redit il ya
un premier dossier c'est les engagements
pris par nokia
lorsque on a donné à tort alcatel à
nokia c'est une erreur stratégique
colossal il fallait que à ce moment là
l'état investisse au capital d'alcatel
et pousse la recherche et développement
d'alcatel
aujourd'hui on aurait un acteur français
de la 5 g et puis le deuxième dossier
majeur c'est que nokia veut vendre
beaucoup de matériel en france dans le
cadre de la 5 g et nous sommes dans une
activité embaument donc la conjonction
des deux éléments fait que l'état
français n'a strictement aucune raison
de baisser les bras
dans ce dossier ça serait une reculade
et une pantalonnade total si l'état
français ne prend pas des mesures
comparables est ce que j'ai évoqué il ya
quelques instants
merci beaucoup christian saint-etienne
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france nous avoir apporté votre analyse
hommes le nouveau premier ministre jean
castex a livré ses premiers mots à
l'assemblée nationale ce matin il a
prévenu qu une crise économique sans
précédent était à prévoir à écouter il
n'aura échappé à personne et en
particulier et en particulier avoue même
que ce nouveau gouvernement entre en
fonctions dans un contexte très
particulier
une crise une crise sanitaire d'une
ampleur exceptionnelle qui vous le savez
n'est pas terminée une crise économique
et sociale qui a déjà commencé et qui
s'annonce comme étant sans doute la plus
difficile que la france l'europe et le
monde auront à affronter depuis la crise
de 1929 avec madame la députée les
valeurs qui sont les miennes avec les
valeurs qui sont les miennes j'ai
l'honneur j'ai l'honneur de diriger ce
gouvernement qui sera un gouvernement de
combat qui sera un gouvernement
tourné vers l'efficacité qui sera un
gouvernement de dialogue qui sera un
gouvernement des territoires
et voilà les premiers mots de jean
castex matin à l'assemblée nationale le
premier ministre qui a planté le décor
première crise une crise plutôt
économique inédite à venir et à un
gouvernement je le cite deux combats de
dialogue et de territoires alors est ce
la fin de l'idée de start up nation cher
au président le nouveau chemin que veut
tracer emmanuel macron passe-t-il par
une nouvelle doctrine économique c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexis poulain cofondateur du monde
moderne bonsoir alexis poulain à vos
côtés loïk le floch prigent ancien grand
dirigeant d'entreprise bonsoir à vous
également loïk le floch prigent alors
baptême du feu aujourd'hui pour le
premier ministre tout d'abord petite
question à l'analyse que vous êtes avec
six poulains vous l'avez trouvé comment
ce premier ministre plutôt à l'aise
devant les députés
oui plutôt à l'aise alors il va falloir
s'habituer au style castex qui est quand
même d'une certaine lenteur de ces
ampoules et il ya l'accent donc c'est
c'est particulier on n'est pas habitué à
ça l'on n'avait edouard philippe qui
était quand même un peu plus vif un peu
plus moderne
il ya un côté un peu suranné dans la
façon de s'exprimer de jean castex qui
fait que b on est tendu à sa parole on
attend un peu quand ça arrive les
parfois c'est un peu long à arriver
après il sait très bien ce qu'il veut il
l'a dit il a les valeurs qui sont les
siennes le faire un gouvernement de
combat
il n'est pas dupe il sait que ce qui
arrive est une crise économique d'une
ampleur inédite
maintenant qu'ils parlent de
gouvernement de combat très bien on
aimerait savoir avec quelles armes ce
gouvernement va aller au combat
alors on va voir ses armes gouvernement
dont combat diallo territoire
on est loin loïk le floch prigent de de
cette idée de start up nation cher
emmanuel macron on est loin dans les
mots mais maintenant il faut transformer
les mots en actions alors sur le film
dans st il ya deux ou trois choses à
faire et on va juger les mots sur les
actions on peut la peine de continuer à
a passé du temps sur les mots et niveau
sur les mots alors la première chose
c'est que nos entreprises on a un
caillou dans la chaussure qui est celui
des impôts de production inventer quand
on enlevait la taxe professionnelle dont
combat à 3 6% dans la chaussure
c'est à dire que on et 3,6 pour cent qui
enlève la marge
alors est ce que oui ou non on a en
temps les chefs d'entreprise et salariés
qui depuis des années il
pourquoi à ton change est apte à ce
professionnel pour avoir proféré 6% qui
sont un problème vis-à-vis de la
concurrence internationale
on est sujet deuxième sujet pose
industrielle est ce que on arrête de
considérer que l'ensemble de l'industrie
est coupable coupable donc c'est trop
grand mais coupable et à chaque fois qui
a une occasion de lui dire le mal qu'on
pense d'elle on le fait alors hier
c'était il faut absolument vous allez en
chômage partiel
le lendemain il faut surtout que vous
sauviez sachez bien que le chômage
partiel va être contrôlé ensuite environ
vous envoie les inspecteurs du travail
ensuite on allait acheter de
l'environnement des bois qu'il faut
faire il faut envoyer vos sentiments
les inspecteurs du fisc c'est à dire que
les entreprises sont effectivement
depuis des années mais surtout depuis
quelques mois à la main d administration
qui disent vous êtes mauvais vous êtes
méchant vous n'êtes pas bien et il faut
que vous alliez landrush mac
je pense qu'il faut un moment avoir un
discours bienveillant bienveillant à
l'égard des industriels et ce discours
bienveillant qui doit être suivi en
dehors des mots des prêts des chefs
d'état comme des ministres et des
présidents et des premiers ministres
il faut soit suivre effet les faits
c'est ça c'est nous voulons avoir une
administration bienveillante dans les
années qui viennent et surtout dans les
mois qui viennent bienveillante dire que
nous ne sommes pas en train d'essayer
faire de l'argent sur des salariés ce
n'est pas vrai les salariés ont ils
travaillé
voilà la situation telle qu'elle est
alors si jamais on appelle ces notions à
ce moment là on pourra dire qui a
peut-être à grammont combat et de
conquérir des territoires mais bon
maintenant je ne avec moi je n'ai que
des mots alexis poulain vous êtes
d'accord on n'a que des démos ses tâches
ou alors c'est un chemin économique
radicalement différent que nous nous
apprêtons à prendre comment vous vous
sentez une chose mais cette présidence
du faso est celle de la communication
politique à outrance on a beaucoup de
vos et très peu d'action et on a
toujours des discours on attend
d'ailleurs le discours du 14 juillet de
vannes elle macron qui a précédé le
discours de jean castex choses assez
inédite pour une fois encore passer de
la pommade lancé de grands discours mais
évidemment ce sont les sais qu'ils
feront que la france pourra sortir de
cette crise internationale la tête haute
il ya un genou et là tels que c'est
présenté aujourd'hui on peut avoir peur
d'une vente à la découpe de faillites
massives
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron le disait
lors d'une allocution précédentes et je
ne vois pas aujourd'hui comment il
pourrait changer sa politique pour
justement éviter le krach a annoncé
c'est le drame français c'est à dire
qu'on a à la fois des énarques qui sont
à la tête de l'état et à la tête des
entreprises et ces gens là où une
certaine vision des choses de commandes
vrai marché des entreprises
oublie trop souvent de tissu économique
que sont les pme les tpe
or c'est le poumon économique à la fois
en france mais aussi en europe et
ailleurs et c'est ce qui fait le succès
de l'allemagne par exemple en france on
a de dieu que pour le cac40 qui parce
que justement ça permet quand on est une
arme de passer de la cour cac 40 un coup
au gouvernement et vice versa c'est pas
ça l'économie d'économie c'est un tout
et je crois que les chefs d'entreprise
aujourd'hui ont effectivement besoin
d'être assuré mais plus que être assurés
s'est assuré que l'activité va pouvoir
reprendre
le confinement tel qu'il a été fait de
manière massive il a peut-être permis
d'endiguer cette circulation du virus
mais il nous emmène tout droit vers une
crise économique d'une ampleur inédite
et malheureusement les aides d'état
devons faire que creuser la dette et ne
vont pas sauver autant d'entreprises que
ce qui va être annoncé dans les discours
combatif de jean castex ou des modèles
maintenant c'est vrai que la crise
économique voilà il fait plutôt peur
parce que jean castex parler d'une crise
économique la plus difficile depuis 1929
il agite le chiffon rouge le premier
ministre où il est dans la réalité
loïk le floch prigent je cours je pense
qu'il faut raison garder c'est à dire
que on dit que la pandémie aide
exceptionnelle et que par conséquent
c'est normal que tout ce qui arrive on
l'apprend amy n'a pas été exceptionnelle
elle a été elle a généré la peur la peur
a été générée par le discours
gouvernemental mais disons que il ya eu
des morts su plaire beaucoup plus
important là les belles bagnoles et la
grippe peuvent donc on n'allait pas se
laisser c'est exceptionnel surtout dans
les mots alors en l'occurrence en ce qui
concerne les entreprises et on va dire
les industriels caraïbes au sens
l'emploi c'est les pme tpe
c'est pas aller dans une reprise sera
aujourd'hui on se met à parler des
entreprises et regarder ses terres il
aurait maintenant c'est pas ça le sujet
le sujet ce sont les petits des
entreprises et les hôtes et les
entreprises de taille intermédiaire qui
ont souffert qui ont été demandés
quelques sous en trésorerie qui les ont
eu raison plus grossièrement seulement
la moitié d'entre elles ont eu les
prenne l'envié par l'état donc s'est
étirée c'est un premier problème de
trésorerie
et derrière il y a le le fait que l'on
est en train les interroger aujourd'hui
pour le bas savoir si ayant eut touché
chômage partiel il y avait vraiment
droit si ils ont bien fait tout ce qu'il
fallait pour l'environnement 6,6 à plat
et je pense que si l'inspection du
travail 6 mai et qu'elle nous dit que
effectivement on a mal agi avec des
salariés alors ça lol le le le ce sera
le comble c'est un goal est l'exception
oui elle existe vraiment
problème il faut qu'on rêve c'est-à-dire
et sa gueule nous acceptons de
bienveillants à l'égard des entreprises
et des pme et des tpe ou pas ce problème
n'est pas réglé et tous les chefs
d'entreprise pourrait vous le dire
à l exception vous êtes d'accord avec ce
diagnostic parce que pardonnez moi je
vous coupe mais mais quand même si on a
été un des systèmes les plus généreux du
monde
retournez bon bain quand même la moitié
des salariés du privé ont chômage bien
qu'elle je crois que c'est c'est on est
généreux mais au prix d'une tête qui
égale aux années mais qu'est-ce que vous
rouliez faire quoi je n'ai pas de doute
et de solutions heureusement qu'on a pu
avoir ce matelas mais malheureusement on
n'a fait que retarder le saut dans le
vide
c'est à dire que oui certaines
entreprises ont reçu des aides elles
vont pouvoir aider chômage partiel va
faire qu'on va demander beaucoup
d'efforts aux salariés en disant que
vous allez travailler plus et gagner
beaucoup moins parce que sinon c'est la
porte alors que on aura c'est peut-être
essayer de préserver l'activité
c'est pas le fait seulement de la france
bien sûr cette crise est mondiale et la
réponse a été malheureusement tardi dans
l'urgence et ce qui fait qu'on est
aujourd'hui en train de gérer avec deux
trois mois de retard ce qui est en train
de se passer
donc on ne va pas éviter malheureusement
l'entrée de de milliers d'hosties c'est
dans le chômage de certains dans la
précarité
les nombreuses faillites et ça c'est
dommageable mais il n'y a pas de
solution magique bien entendu l1 depuis
sa sortie on abolit les 35 heures ont
réécrit le code du travail qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire
je conteste complètement que le chômage
partiel célébrée comme une victoire et
était effectivement et victoire
considère qu' il fallait donner aux
entreprises dans la mesure du possible
nous continuer à travailler en prenant
les précautions nécessaires pour la
santé ce ce qui a été fait dans en
allemagne et ils ont eu raison des
accords redémarrer une entreprise après
que de l'ensemble de l'entreprise soit
accès chez elle pendant un ou deux mois
c'est très difficile et nous vivons ce
problème en danger l'entreprise de façon
frontale et lierait
extrêmement difficile donc premièrement
deuxièmement je crois que maintenant il
faut que tout le monde s'y met
effectivement et qu' il faut laisser aux
seules entreprises la possibilité de
discuter avec leurs salariés pour faire
les choses si jamais on continue à faire
une politique nationale et hassar et
d'aider les affaires avec des grenades
différents âges et variées on peut pas
s'en sortir on peut s'en sortir que le
dirigeant d'entreprise avec ses salariés
qui dit voilà comment on fait maintenant
pour y arriver et ça ça se fait
naturellement
si jamais on les laisse facilement qu'on
communique pas autant qu'on communique
la communication gouvernementale aide
est catastrophiquement dans le
confinement et s'il aimait continue à
être catastrophique
eh bien nous irons la catastrophe mais
c'est sûrement en partie importante
parce que la communication était folle
que nous sommes dans ces situations
complètement rocambolesque
merci à tous les 2 alexis poulain loïk
le floch prigent d'avant était avec nous
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de l'australie plus de 5
millions de personnes sont à nouveau à
l'art est confiné à melbourne mais
également de l'océanic qui s'inquiètent
et puis direction londres qui a annoncé
reprendre ses livraisons d'armes à
l'arabie saoudite un an après les avoir
suspendus après des suspicions de crimes
de guerre au yémen reste événements
[Musique]
je suis mais c'est pas possible c'est
rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer elle tout seul dans
sa cuisine
je me suis aperçu que c'était bien que
difficiles qui avait une équipe de 25
usines et autour pour nous pour nos
fournisseurs pour nos équipes c'était
essentiel d'ouvrir le plus tôt possible
beaucoup des mid de la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le comte d'avant il
était formidable et qu'on a envie de le
retrouver je pensais que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et ben ça m'a
rendu plus intolérant alors parfois elle
s'était d'ailleurs je voudrais vous
poser justement délirer autour d'un
dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche la
patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tony que le monde avant
[Musique]
je
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
et
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il lui
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre 21h30 heure de
paris en direct sur rt france melbourne
en australie
confiné plus de 5 millions de personnes
sont concernées les habitants 1 doivent
rester chez eux sauf pour des raisons
professionnelles pour faire de
l'exercice
prendre des rendez vous médicaux ou
acheter des produits première nécessité
une mise à l'isolément qui durera au
moins six semaines ce sont les 191
nouveaux car en 24 heures qui ont alerté
le gouvernement écouter sur la question
de la fermeture générale de melbourne
c'est une question dont le premier
ministre daniel andrews m'informer c'est
bien sûr sur la base de leurs conseils
et des conseils que j'ai reçu du médecin
chef
alors c'était nécessaire j'espère que ce
ne sera pas aussi longs que les six
semaines annonce et j'espère que ce sera
pour une période aussi courte que
possible mais vu la gravité de la
situation avec leicester initiaux le
confinement est la mesure la plus sage
que le premier ministre de victoria et
ses conseils auraient pu prendre
français qui se trouvent à gué longue en
australie au total plus de 5 millions de
personnes sont invités à rester chez eux
pour une durée de six semaines
interdiction stricte de sortie du
domicile uniquement en cas de première
nécessité les activités en plein air
sont interdites les cafés les bars les
restaurants sont fermés au public le
ouvert pour la vente à emporter les
vacances d'hiver ont été prolongé d'une
semaine supplémentaire pour tous les
étudiants
l'état du victoria est désormais fermé
coupés du reste du pays les frontières
avec ses états voisins sont fermés
l'australie méridionale mais également
la nouvelle galles du sud dans la plus
grande ville et sydney depuis mardi soir
c'est un fait rare dans l'histoire de
l'australie il faut remonter à 1919 et
la pandémie de grippe espagnole pour
voir les frontières entre ces deux états
la nouvelle galles du sud et le victoria
fermer cette nouvelle phase de
confinement va également affecter de
nombreux commerces et restaurants
ce mercredi de nombreuses personnes se
sont ruées pour une dernière à sortir
dans six semaines de confinement
nombreux restaurateurs estiment que ce
second confinement d'un rendre laurie
encore plus difficile certains ne se
sont pas encore remises du premier plein
de compliments qu'il faut déjà refermé
les restaurants le secteur les
professionnels de la restauration estime
à 80 5%
la perte d'affaires pour cette seconde
phase 2 de confinement pour leur venir
en aide le gouvernement va prolonger
l'aide d'état mise en place au début de
la pandémie à kinmen d'état qui va leur
permettre une aide financière et pour
que les restaurateurs et les
professionnels puissent payer leurs
charges puisse payer leur leurs employés
il y a vraiment une tolérance zéro pour
cette seconde phase de confinement à
melbourne dans les tours daddy dans les
immeubles d'habitation environ 3000
personnes ont été reçu l'ordre de rester
enfermés chez eux ils dire avant le
confinement parce que 75 cas ont été
détectés dans une seul tour d'habitation
cette mesure est à la plus stricte
jamais mise en place en australie depuis
le début de la pandémie est le retour de
coronavirus en océanie inquiète
également de la de l'australie
l'occasion pour nous de s'intéresser à
la situation des territoires d'outre-mer
français présents dans cette zone comme
la polynésie française
seuls 62 cas confirmés ont été détectés
la polynésie a tout de même été
peaufinée entièrement du 20 mars au 21
mai dans ce territoire très touristique
les conséquences économiques sont
importantes
3 points de pib en moins par mois de
confinement mais la réouverture des
lignes aériennes inquiète la population
d'une éventuelle propagation du virus
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec mon état et brotherson merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france bétail
voilà députés députés de polynésie le
retour du corps d'un virus dans le
pacifique sud ça vous inquiète où vous
vous sentez à l'abri
votre situation géographique alors ça
nous inquiète autant sur le plan
sanitaire paix sur le plan économique
puisque comme un peu pompeusement on est
chez nous tourisme est un pas essentiel
de nos ressources ils représentent 22 %
du pib et pendant la période de
confinement et de blocage des lignes
c'était un secteur complètement à
l'arrêt donc aujourd'hui on est un peu
on y est on est obligé de faire la
balance entre rétablir le tourisme est
tout de même anticiper une éventuelle
arrivée de nouveaux cas de de colo
pardonnez moi j'ai un peu écorché votre
fonction tout à l'heure qui a été un
petit peu rapidement passer sur mon
écran vous êtes député de polynésie
française en tant qu'élu vous êtes très
inquiet justement par ses répercussions
due à la crise sanitaire
on vous sent inquiet puisque on a fait
une estimation avec les services du
gouvernement
vous savez on a déjà à peu près 40% de
perse de personnes qui n'ont pas
d'emploi en polynésie ça c'était avant
le pot vide et on a d'ici la fin de
l'année et vision de 15 mille chômeurs
de plus de onze mille dans le secteur
touristique
donc on est on est très inquiet de la
crise sociale et la crise économique qui
est en train de suivre la clé sanitaires
aujourd'hui clairement vous en appelez
au gouvernement on imagine que voilà
comme tout le territoire vous avez eu
des dns que c'est toujours le cas
aujourd'hui ce que les autorités sont là
pour vous soutenir
alors je crois que c'est une crise d'une
ampleur inédite depuis 1929 et il faut
une réponse à la hauteur des enjeux
pour l'instant aussi bien le
gouvernement local que l'état on parlait
au plus pressé en gérer finalement la
situation de crise immédiate mais il
faut aujourd'hui c'est trop jeté un
engin
un plan de résilience et peut-être
réorienter l'économie du moins pour la
polynésie puisque je vous donnais un
chiffre en polynésie où il n'ya pas
d'hiver et où tout pousse on a
aujourd'hui 90 % de ce qui est consommé
qui est apportée il faut il faut
absolument dans cette relance changer de
paradigme et et aller vers une économie
avec moins de dépendance vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur et plus de résilience
aujourd'hui la situation sanitaire est
quand même je dirais satisfaisante en
polynésie où sont les services de santé
par exemple en guyane on sait qu'il n'ya
pas plus de quinze lits en réanimation
au moment où l'épidémie a frappé
qu'en est il chez vous en polynésie
alors un peu comme tout le monde on
n'était pas du tout préparé quand il ya
eu la crise au début
entre temps le gouvernement et l'état
ont réagi on a on a élevé le niveau
d'équipement que ce son respirateur que
ce soit en capacité d'accueil dans l'est
dans les hôpitaux on on est en capacité
d'avoir à peu près une soixantaine voir
une centaine de personnes en même temps
on va dire en traitement l'eau
maintenant on n'a pas suffisamment de
masques on avait attendu 22 mille
masques pour pouvoir faire des tests à
grande échelle
on en a eues aujourd'hui on manque
également d'oxygène donc pour les
respirateurs on a les appareils mais on
manque d'oxygène voilà il mais on essaye
le gouvernement les ministères de la
santé locale en collaboration avec
l'état essaie de de pallier ses manques
on sait que les lignes aériennes vont
rouvrir à destination de la polynésie
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour le
tourisme mais c'est une source
d'inquiétude pour la propagation du
virus
alors c'est une chose inquiétude vous
savez à partir du mois de juillet nous
avons 1500 fonctionnaires le bêta qui
doivent venir relever leurs collègues
qui sont en fin de fin d'affectation en
polynésie ce sont des personnes qui
viennent de métropole où il y a encore
basses et lakovic 19
il ya encore des gens qui meurent tous
les jours donc on est on est un peu
inquiet de ce côté là et puis surtout
évoqué l'éventuelle arrivée de touristes
en provenance des états unis
ou alors on a on a perdu mon style
brotherson en direct de polynésie je
rappelle comment taille personnes et
députés de polynésie française nous a
donc exposé la situation sur la
polynésie
une décision qui suscite
l'incompréhension un an après l'arrêt de
vente d'armes suspecté d'être utilisé
par l'arabie saoudite au yémen le
royaume uni annonce la reprise de ses
exportations vers ryad
une décision qui arrive au moment où les
nations unies annoncent que le yémen
ravagée par six ans de guerre est à
nouveau au bord de la famine les
explications de lille à faa'a à mouzon
c'est une volte face qui pourrait coûter
la vie à des milliers d'innocents
un an après s'être conformé à la justice
britannique qui lui interdisait les
ventes d'armes en direction de l'arabie
saoudite londres annonce tambour battant
la reprise de ses exportations pour la
ministre britannique du commerce il ne
s'agit pas seulement de relancer les
ventes mais bel et bien de rattraper un
retard
le gouvernement va désormais commencer à
rattraper le retard dans la délivrance
des licences de vente d'armes à l'arabie
saoudite et à ses partenaires de la
coalition qui s'est accumulée depuis le
20 juin de l'année dernière le 20 juin
2019 en effet la cour d'appel
britannique a interdit l'octroi de
nouvelles licences d'exportation d'armes
vers riyad de crainte que ces
équipements ne soient utilisés dans la
guerre au yémen le royaume uni
avait alors décidé de réexaminer les
violations présumées du royaume
wahhabite dans ce petit pays de la
péninsule arabique et malgré la
découverte de violations possibles du
droit international humanitaire
londres estime qu'il s'agit seulement
d'un incident isolé dans son communiqué
au parlement la ministre britannique du
commerce va même plus loin elle
renouvelle sa confiance à l'arabie
saoudite et à ses alliés malgré les
alertes répétées des instances
internationales
l'arabie saoudite à la sincère
intentions et la capacité de se
conformer au droit international
humanitaire
comprenez fermez le ban il n'ya rien à
voir
plusieurs organisations internationales
et humanitaires accusent les forces
dirigées par l'arabie saoudite d'avoir
enfreint le droit international
humanitaire depuis le début de son
engagement dans le conflit en 2015
notamment en bombardant des écoles des
hôpitaux ou encore des infrastructures
alimentaire la situation au yémen est
aujourd'hui qualifié par de nombreux
observateurs comme l'une des pires
crises humanitaires du monde
presque chaque enfant au yémen 12
millions a aujourd'hui besoin d'une aide
humanitaire
des millions pourraient mourir du
choléra et de la diarrhée parce que
leurs familles n'ont pas l'eau
l'assainissement et l'hygiène dont elles
ont besoin
les écoles des hôpitaux l'eau la
nutrition tous les systèmes dont les
enfants ont besoin s'effondre en
justifiant la reprise de ses ventes les
britanniques jette un voile pudique sur
les crimes qui pourraient être commis
avec leurs armes
pourtant il y a quelques jours londres
s'est montré particulièrement attentive
à la question des droits de l'homme en
annonçant une série de sanctions à
l'encontre de 49 personnes et
organisations dont 25 russe et 20
saoudiens sont sonnés par les
britanniques de violations des droits
humains
une façon de faire taire les critiques
accusant le royaume uni de fermer les
yeux sur la provenance des capitaux
étrangers hébergés dans la capitale
britannique une décision d'ailleurs jugé
regrettable côté russe nous ne pouvons
que regretter ces mesures inamicale bien
évidemment le principe de réciprocité
sera appliquée en matière de vente
d'armes la france n'est pas en reste et
malgré les déclarations du ministère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères qui
qualifie
le conflit au yémen de sale guerre
l'hexagone concerne de très bonnes
relations commerciales avec l'arabie
saoudite selon un rapport publié le mois
dernier par le ministère des armées
le royaume wahhabite est le deuxième
client de la france en matière de
livraison de matériel de guerre
en 2019 la france a livré pour plus d'1
virgule 3 milliards d'euros de matériel
de guerre à l'arabie saoudite
pour rappel depuis 2015 elle la guerre
au yémen a fait plus de cent mille morts
dont de nombreux civils
sans compter les nombreuses victimes de
la crise humanitaire que le conflit a
engendré mais comme disent les anglais
business is business
elle pour en parler nous retrouvons
direct de londres catherine chaque tam
spécialiste du moyen-orient c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur on soir
catherine à chaque dame merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors pas de
crimes de guerre mais des incidents
isolés c'est l'argument relevé par
londres pour légitimer sa décision
pourtant l'année dernière le
gouvernement britannique avait lui même
admis que les armes fabriquées au
royaume uni avait joué un rôle central
dans le bombardement du yémen comment
comprendre ce retournement économique
naissante et y est je pense que c'est la
nécessité économique
le renommer me gênait pas refusé de
l'argent aujourd'hui et la vente d armes
à l'arabie saoudite est très pratique
l'endroit a toujours suit ce principe
l'arabie saoudite est un allié très
tactique est intéressant dans la région
le royaume uni est donc prêt à détourner
le nez regard face aux crimes commis au
yémen et la logique sous jacente est un
peu biaisé souvent le gouvernement
adopte la position suivante comme le
gouvernement du yémen est considéré
comme un gouvernement illégitime
alors tout ce qui pourrait arriver à ce
gouvernement aux individus qui lui sont
liés il n'a pas d'importance de l'ain
point de vue car ils considèrent
soutenir le pouvoir légitime au yémen et
les se considère donc pas comme opérant
en dehors du droit international c'est
une voix lui très biaisée
laissé seul hic adopte le gouvernement
britannique et c'est pour cela que cela
peut coïncider avec des politiques
contre les violations des droits
humanitaires donc le croit et demi peut
continuer à dire qu'il défend le droit
humanitaire et le droit international
les cela concerne en premier lieu les
intérêts financiers du royaume uni et là
que très peu à voir avec la recherche
d'une solution au conflit au yémen où
les morts au yémen où le moyen de
rationaliser des morts civiles au yémen
tout cela est écartée parce que cela ne
correspond pas au discours général et
ceux que l'on voit aujourd'hui c'est un
exemple tout à fait classique tient de
posture politique adoptée par le royaume
uni alors cette annonce intervient il
faut le préciser au lendemain d'une
vague de sanction inédite a imposé par
le royaume uni à 20 saoudien pour vol et
violation aux droits humains soupçonné
d'avoir joué un rôle dans le meurtre en
2018 du journaliste khashoggi un jamal
khashoggi à istanbul selon vous est ce
qu'il ya un lien ce qui vaut le voir
[Musique]
d'un côté le royaume uni déclare qu'il
agit contre ces violations des droits de
l'homme parce que effectivement cet
assassinat à l'est était un crime
flagrant ne pouvait pas être défendue
donc le royaume uni devait agir
ce n'est pas forcément ce qu'il fallait
faire car nous ne savons pas encore à ce
jour si les personnes accusées
c'est véritablement un coupable on
n'essaie pas en tout cas si ce sont bien
eux qui ont créé la décision on ne sait
pas où les décisions étaient prises en
arabie saoudite
s'agissant du yémen il s'agit d'une
décision du gouvernement de perpétrer
des crimes contre l'humanité au yémen le
royaume uni est prêt à agir contre des
individus mais pas contre un
gouvernement qui tour le royaume uni est
un as des et non seulement un allié mais
également un partenaire très utile
notamment en matière de politique
étrangère
donc c'est une posture très pratique
pour le royaume uni
ils agissent parfois mais pas
systématiquement parce que politiquement
ils doivent ménager l'arabie saoudite
ils doivent continuer à défendre leurs
intérêts qui sont liées aux leurres pour
le royaume-uni l'arabie saoudite agit
dans la lignée de leurs intérêts propres
donc ils pourront continuer ses actions
ils seront ils bénéficieront de toute
fin à l'impunité du monde
ma dernière question l'onu décrire le
conflit au yémen comme la pire crise
humanitaire au monde
quelle réaction du côté justement des
nations unies et des associations
humanitaires face à cette décision
britannique connaît point
c'est une question difficile certaines
personnes vont s'exprimer vous prendre
la parole contre la leur à une grille en
critiquant justement à l'hypocrisie de
leurs positions mais il ne s'agit là que
de mots et jusqu'à ce que des actions
surprises sur le terrain il est très
facile de dire ce qu'il faut faire ou
faudrait faire au yémen la guerre doit
cesser on doit apporter une aide et au
civil il doit apporter de la nourriture
et une aide humanitaire en général
au yémen mais est-ce que cela va arriver
ça y est pas sûr car lorsqu'on parle des
humanitaires la question est tout de
suite comment s'assurer que cette aide
arrive bien aux bonnes personnes et
n'arrive pas plutôt à des extrémistes
c'est un problème que tous les partis
doivent étudier et un résoudre au yémen
il est difficile de justifier l'action
du royaume uni les autres pays seront
tout à fait prêt à détourner le regard
si cela correspond également à la
rhétorique qu'ils produisent et d'autres
pays serait également tout à fait prêt
sans doute à faire commerce avec
l'arabie saoudite
la différence c'est qu'on n'en parle pas
dans les journaux
merci catherine chaque can chaque dame
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et c'est la fin de cette émission
se retrouve à 22 heures pile pour un
point complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
where france pour renault hommes ce sont
des entreprises qui sont je dirais en
fête permanente on va pas obliger les
entreprises ont contexte actuel à garder
leurs salariés ça n'a pas de sens ça
fait longtemps que je soutiens l'idée d'
emploi garanti
c'est à dire on on propose un emploi
fixe et personne n'était dans lequel on
retrouve un autre job du monde on n'a
aucune vision aucune
et ça c'est malheureusement dans tous
les domaines au lieu de dépenser des
milliards comme ça pour rien il faudrait
mieux les dépensés pour former les gens
et les replacer ailleurs
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck fallu que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
construire les fiches avec les acteurs
associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons on est dans une
espèce de déni collectif on ne veut pas
croire ce qu'on sait et scientifique
parle quand même de la sixième
extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
et à d'autres experts qui contestent
leur six personnes non non c'est pas
vrai il ya des climats tout c'est
maintenant et non ce n'est pas rien à
part il ya des gens qui ne sont pas des
chercheurs qui parlent que la presse met
en avant parce que il faut que du débat
mais il ya plus de débat aujourd'hui il
n'y a plus aucun débat ce changement
climatique et on va vers une vraie par
une catastrophe va vers une vraie
catastrophe et on est incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas d'être pessimiste tout
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons de vue et des demies
il n'a pas d'ennemi l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie
trop missiles malgré la polémique
mondiale sur l'efficacité de cette
combinaison l'ats le porte parole de la
police
nous avions déjà commencé à utiliser le
protocole avec les boutiques préoccupe
bien avant que le match ne commence en
effet par sénégal la chloroquine
domaniale est utilisé pendant des
décennies et des décennies ça pourrait
faire sourire les sénégalais quand
j'entends de 17,2 au sénat il n'y a pas
de signes qui montrent en outre ce
protocole voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encourage la fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fond pour en remettre en cause la pensée
des groupes de pression voix l'étude
démontre la nocivité de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine au nom de la peur de la mort
notre ministre a interdit immédiatement
son utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société
factice dont certains des employés ont
des qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique
les technocrates les activistes et de
nombreux journalistes ne s'intéressent
qu'à la partie qui va dans leur sens et
censure ou dévalorise le reste fonds
décide de ce que le peuple doit penser
[Musique]
la crise du coronavirus s'aggrave en
amérique latine situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
le président brésilien janet jackson à
rosny la gravité la date en 2000 il a
été élu c'est par un dictateur il reste
encore populaire et donc évidemment sa
façon de se comporter par rapport au
virus a de l'impact auprès des
brésiliens aujourd'hui le gouvernement
travaille fortement pour s'approprier
les territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaît ou aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
une trump est vraiment passé à côté du
problème et dans mes souvenirs c'est la
première fois qu'on assiste à des
manifestations de masse où la majorité
des américains sont sympathisants de ces
mobilisations
ils savent qu'il y à de la violence
policière et ils veulent que ces
violences est ce selon vous 99% de la
police qui est impliqué dans une
fusillade n'est jamais condamné est ce
qu'il y à une impunité assumer il y a
une culture de l'impunité dans la police
américaine
le problème c'est le système
institutionnel et c'est pour ça que même
après avoir eu un président noir
cela continue finalement les gens
demandent une justice sociale autant
qu'une justice raciale mais également
économique
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre elle les musées avec trois mois
de nos activités ou les billetteries
sont à l'arrêt l'impact financier est
énorme
ce sera un redémarrage sous conditions
avec port du masque obligatoire
distanciation physique gestion des flux
que ce que nous attendons c'est
effectivement la possibilité de rouvrir
sans ces mesures barrières le plus vite
possible
on retrouvera pas le marché que nous
avons quitté en 2021 il faudra
reconstruire le marché se reprendre à
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
[Musique]
à chacun son enquête après l'assemblée
nationale d investigation judiciaire une
enquête indépendante lancée par l'elysée
le sénat où sa commission sur la gestion
de l'épidémie de kobe 19 en france
les auditions ont débuté aujourd'hui
première entendue
les représentants du grand st jean
particulièrement touchée avec près de
3500 morts le royaume-uni reprend la
vente d'armes à l'arabie saoudite ces
transactions avaient été suspendues l'an
dernier par décision de justice
en cause des craintes de l'utilisation
de ce matériel militaire dans ces crimes
de guerre au yémen
et hier la secrétaire d'état au commerce
international britannique a affirmé
qu'il ne s'agissait que d' acte isolé
la chine pose ses conditions sur un tout
autre dossier celui du nucléaire
pékin se dit disposé à discuter d'un
accord russo américain sur l'armement si
washington s'engagent à réduire son
arsenal à sa hauteur les etats unis
disposent d'une réserve dix fois plus
élevée que celle de la chine
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france après
l'assemblée nationale des investigations
judiciaires et une enquête indépendante
lancée par l'elysée c'est au tour du
sénat d'ouvrir une commission sur la
gestion de l'épidémie de kobe 19 en
france les auditions ont débuté ce soir
le point avec notre reporter bcm chili
c'est aujourd'hui que s'ouvre les
auditions dans le cadre de la commission
d'enquêté du sénat sur la crise du
coronavirus aujourd'hui au sénat est
auditionné jean rottner qui est le
président de la région grand est une
audition en vidéoconférence devant une
trentaine de sénateurs disposé à lui
poser certaines questions notamment sur
la gestion du covan à virus dans sa
région pourquoi jean rottner est le
premier à être auditionné dans le cadre
de cette commission denquête ou
simplement qu'à la région grand est a
été la première à être touchée par la
crise du coronavirus souvenez vous
c'était lors de cette messe pastorale à
mulhouse où les premiers cas de kovy de
19 ont été détectés et rapporté le
président de la région grand est bien
sûr est revenu sur la gestion de ce
coronavirus dans sa région sur les
difficultés qu'il a pu avoir sur
l'inaction du gouvernement il a expliqué
cette pénurie de masques ce manque de
matériel ou encore de produits a
expliqué comment il a dû lui-même ainsi
que sa région ont commandé des masques
de 6 millions de masques et les
problèmes qui ont dû avoir pour ses
livraisons différents sénateurs ont pris
la parole pour poser les questions au
président de région je vous propose
d'écouter notamment quelques réactions
de sénateurs et sénatrices présent il ya
eu des tas de problèmes pendant cette
période épouvantable et donc il est
important que nous puissions faire notre
travail de contrôle savoir s'il ya eu
des fautes de commise et surtout avoir
un retour d'expérience pour ne pas
recommencer la prochaine fois sy sarr ça
se reproduit dès le 5 mars 1 et il a été
très précis je m'en tenir dès le 5 mars
il prend conscience aussi que me
présente région mais aussi comme
urgentiste que
il est face à une crise sanitaire sans
précédent avec des personnes qui
arrivent aux urgences des personnes qui
décèdent et est donc voilà la question
qui se pose est que nous devons poser en
tant que parlementaires c'est de savoir
si l'êta a réagi à la juste mesure de la
laërt qui était très vite posé une série
de questions auxquelles s'est prêté le
président de la région un grand test
dans le cadre de cette enquête sur le
coronavirus à partir de demain ce sera
au tour de madame josiane chevalier
qu'est la préfète du haut rhin ainsi que
de l'ex président de la rs du haut-rhin
à risque pas y répondre aux questions
des sénateurs dans le cadre de cette
longue série d'auditions et dans le
cadre de cette commission d' enquête sur
le coronavirus après la région grand est
bien ce sera aux différentes régions de
france
objectif pour le sénat comprendre les
quoi qui a pu avoir pendant cette crise
du coronavirus pour les éviter en cas de
deuxième vague du corona dans le pays
dans cette gestion des crises un nom est
venu souvent l'hydroxyde chloroquine une
étude française publiée hier ne relève
pas du rôle préventif de lui ni de
l'utilisation au long cours de ce
médicament contre le coc u19
de son côté le professeur raoul autre
partisan depuis le début de ce
traitement persiste et signe
en fait le point en images
[Rires]
oh
on peut pas empêcher la vérité de sortir
depuis elle finit toujours par sortir
donc on commence à voir toute une série
de travaux qui sont publiés maintenant
et qui montrent qu'ils tuent en commun
quand on les analyse de montrer tout ce
qu'il ya une efficacité de l'occitan au
quine 1 dans le traitement de la maladie
et qui évite la mortalité et deux dans
la diminution de la persistance du virus
chez jean
[Musique]
là
et que penser de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
je vous propose d'écouter les avis de
thierry lardeux noah médecin généraliste
membre du collectif laissons les
médecins à prescrire et j'en connais mon
président de la fédération à des
médecins de france
j'ai été très surpris qu'on interdise
l'exercice la prescription de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine parce que les
médecins effectivement font pas
n'importe quoi il n'allait pas donner
l'hydroxyde chloroquine à quelqu'un qui
avait des troubles cardiaques
donc c'était pas faire courir un risque
aux patients que dû en faire que de lui
faire prendre de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
moi vous savez j'ai été comme tout le
monde
au bout de quatre jours j'en ai pris
pendant deux jours deux jours et demi
bon j'ai pas supporter le traitement bon
parce que j'avais des nausées
bon on avait plus que des nausées âge je
mettais plus un pied par terre
est-ce que c'était l'effet du virus est
ce que c'était l'effet de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine associé à l'asie drôme usine
j'en sais rien en tous les cas j'ai
arrêté au bout de deux jours et demi
bon voilà ça m'a pas empêché de faire un
épisode fébrile pendant trois jours qui
m'a fait tremper le lit pendant trois
jours mais au 9e 10e et 11e jour mais
mais quand vous êtes atteints ou quand
vous avez des patients bas vous tester
des choses c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
de poison c'est assez amusant de voir
que l'hydroxyde chloroquine qui a été
prescrit à des milliards de boîtes
jusqu'à présent et qui ne posait pas de
problème particulier personnes se
posaient des questions particulières sur
les drogues cicor keane jusque-là
brutalement c'est devenu le diable qui
sortait de sa boîte et la molécule
dramatique dangereuse épouvantable ça
c'est assez c'est assez curieux c'est
assez inexplicable savez moi j'ai j'ai
quelque chose qu une petite anecdote qui
va vous amuser je suis de la région
lorraine
et nous avions dans notre région le
docteur bastien le docteur bastien était
un médecin généraliste de campagne qui
avait remarqué qu' il y avait moyen de
guérir les empoisonnements à l'amanite
phalloïde par un traitement très sympa
de l'aspirine et de la vitamine c est
quelque chose de 13,2 très simple il y a
fallu qu'ils sont toxiques
lui même trois fois dont une fois devant
le lan 7 pour qu'on finisse par
reconnaître que le traitement qu'il
avait proposé contre l'intoxication à
l'amanite phalloïde était le bon
alors vous savez moi je suis habitué à
voir des hommes étrangers qui proposent
des choses un petit peu hors norme et je
suis très intéressé par ça c'est la
curiosité même de la médecine et gérald
darmanin a reçu les syndicats de police
place beauvau surlendemain de sa
nomination le nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur a convié les organisations
syndicales représentant les policiers
une rencontre qui intervient après des
semaines de manifestations chez les
forces de l'orde écoutez les réactions
de certains syndicats à la sortie de
cette réunion
concrètement il n'y a pas de mesures il
va y avoir maintenant des rencontres
bilatérales qui vont être organisées
avec l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales dès la semaine prochaine
ces rencontres permettront à chaque
organisation syndicale de présenter des
revendications d'unsa police évidemment
en tant que force de proposition
présentera les revendications qui sont
celles de de l'ensemble de nos collègues
qui vont bien au delà de décès de notre
organisation syndicale
ces rencontres en tout cas ont pour
objectif véritablement de poser des
choses de dénoncer effectivement des
dysfonctionnements de faire des
propositions concrètes
en tout cas elle s'est engagée à avoir
un discours de vérité voilà on jugera
effectivement par la suite ce qui est
important c'est d'avoir quelqu'un qui
s'est présenté en tout cas comme
quelqu'un étant à disposition en tout
cas d'être disponible de vie avec des
organisations syndicales
déjà reconnaître que et mutations de
crédit que le lendemain d'avoir été
installé place beauvau il reçoit les
organisations syndicales dans le
périmètre police nationale c'est déjà un
point très très positif
maintenant on a bien compris qu'on avait
affaire à un ministre qui veut aller
directement au but
il veut améliorer le quotidien des
policiers donc on ne peut bien
évidemment que s'associer à cette
volonté d'améliorer le quotidien des
policiers en étaient aussi très clair au
delà des mots d'amour
maintenant on veut des actes d'amour et
il a d'ailleurs partagé notre analyse là
dessus et on a compris qu'on avait
affaire à un ministre qui est très
cartésien qui fera toujours dû démontrer
le bien fondé d'une revendication et
fera tout pour l'améliorer le ministre
n'a rien promis donc c'est ça aussi qui
est intéressant c'est que nous on sait
qui détient certaines clés qu'il a
l'oreille du président de la république
mais en tout état de cause il s'est pas
lancé dans la grande annonce démagogique
et nous c'est ce qui nous intéresse
c'est d'avoir quelques actions
pragmatiques qui puisse nous aider dans
la mesure de ses moyens mais qu'ils ne
se lancent pas dans des réformes des
plans quinquennaux des choses comme on
pu faire certains de ses prédécesseurs
et surtout de me paraît entamé à nouveau
des réformes qui porte son nom et qu'on
ne pourrait pas mener à terme un
redémarrage polémique
hier le conseil départemental de
l'environnement et des risques
sanitaires et technologiques de seine
maritime a dit oui à une relance des
activités de lubrizol
il s'agit de la reprise d'une deuxième
unité de production
le site recueille 10 et à rouen avait
déjà rouvert partiellement fin 2019
moins d'un an après avoir subi un énorme
incendie aujourd'hui les élus roanne et
les associations de défense de
l'environnement dénoncent une décision
précipitée tout comme les écologistes et
pour catherine flavigny mer et l'air de
mont-saint-aignan
ce redémarrage est considéré comme
contraignant mais nécessaire bien sûr il
y a certainement encore des conséquences
qu'ils ne sont pas
enfin qui sont encore que l'on peut
respirer par exemple mais vous savez les
odeurs c'est parce qu'il y à n'en plus
de pie ix je prends aussi toutes les
précautions oratoires dans les mots que
j'utilise c'est pas parce qu'on sent
quelque chose que cette chose sera
fatalement la plus nocive possible on ne
peut pas réouvrir bien entendu n'importe
comment mais je pense qu'il est
nécessaire de se couvrir bien sûr et de
prendre des garanties
mais ceci est faisable il faut savoir à
un moment donné si on veut tout de même
protégé sur notre territoire les emplois
en prenant toutes les précautions
voulues ou si on ne le veut pas moi je
suis favorable au fait que vraiment
lubrizol puis ré ouvrir dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et je
pense qu'on est aussi capable de pouvoir
garantir ces conditions là une décision
qui suscite l'incompréhension après un
an d'arrêt devant d'armes suspecté
d'être utilisé par l'arabie saoudite au
yémen le royaume uni annonce la reprise
de ses exportations vers ryad
une décision qui arrive au moment où les
nations unies annoncent que le yémen
ravagée par six en guerre est à nouveau
au bord de la famine les explications de
l'île afin à bozouls c'est une volte
face qui pourrait coûter la vie à des
milliers d'innocents
un an après s'être conformé à la justice
britannique qui lui interdisait les
ventes d'armes en direction de l'arabie
saoudite londres annonce tambour battant
la reprise de ses exportations pour la
ministre britannique du commerce il ne
s'agit pas seulement de relancer les
ventes mais bel et bien de rattraper un
retard
le gouvernement va désormais commencer à
rattraper le retard dans la délivrance
des licences de vente d'armes à l'arabie
saoudite et à ses partenaires de la
coalition qui s'est accumulée depuis le
20 juin de l'année dernière le 20 juin
2019 en effet la cour d'appel
britannique a interdit l'octroi de
nouvelles licences d'exportation d'armes
vers riyad de crainte que ces
équipements ne soient utilisés dans la
guerre au yémen
le royaume uni avait alors décidé de
réexaminer les violations présumées du
royaume wahhabite dans ce petit pays de
la péninsule arabique et malgré la
découverte de violations possibles du
droit international humanitaire
londres estime qu'il s'agit seulement
d'un incident isolé dans son communiqué
au parlement la ministre britannique du
commerce va même plus loin elle
renouvelle sa confiance à l'arabie
saoudite et à ses alliés
malgré les alertes répétées des
instances internationales
l'arabie saoudite à la sincère
intentions et la capacité de se
conformer au droit international
humanitaire
comprenez fermez le ban il n'ya rien à
voir
plusieurs organisations internationales
humanitaires accusent les forces
dirigées par l'arabie saoudite d'avoir
enfreint le droit international
humanitaire depuis le début de son
engagement dans le conflit en 2015
notamment en bombardant des écoles des
hôpitaux ou encore des infrastructures
alimentaire la situation au yémen est
aujourd'hui qualifié par de nombreux
observateurs comme l'une des pires
crises humanitaires du monde
presque chaque enfant au yémen 12
millions a aujourd'hui besoin d'une aide
humanitaire
des millions pourraient mourir du
choléra et de la diarrhée parce que
leurs familles n'ont pas l'eau
l'assainissement et l'hygiène dont elles
ont besoin
les écoles les hôpitaux l'eau la
nutrition tous les systèmes dont les
enfants ont besoin s'effondre en
justifiant la reprise de ses ventes les
britanniques jette un voile pudique sur
les crimes qui pourraient être commis
avec leurs armes
pourtant il y a quelques jours londres
s'est montré particulièrement attentive
à la question des droits de l'homme en
annonçant une série de sanctions à
l'encontre de 49 personnes et
organisations dont 25 russe et 20
saoudien soupçonné par les britanniques
de violations des droits humains
une façon de faire taire les critiques
accusant le royaume uni de fermer les
yeux sur la provenance des capitaux
étrangers hébergés dans la capitale
britannique une décision d'ailleurs jugé
regrettable côté russe nous ne pouvons
que regretter ces mesures inamicale bien
évidemment le principe de réciprocité
sera appliquée en matière de vente
d'armes la france n'est pas en reste
elle malgré les déclarations du
ministère de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères qui qualifiait le conflit au
yémen de sale guerre l'hexagone concerne
de très bonnes relations commerciales
avec l'arabie saoudite selon un rapport
publié le mois dernier par le ministère
des armées
le royaume wahhabite est le deuxième
client de la france en matière de
livraison de matériel de guerre
en 2019 la france a livré pour plus d'1
virgule 3 milliards d'euros de matériel
de guerre à l'arabie saoudite
pour rappel depuis 2015 elle la guerre
au yémen a fait plus de cent mille morts
dont de nombreux civils
sans compter les nombreuses victimes de
la crise humanitaire que le conflit a
engendré mais comme disent les anglais
business is business
selon catherine chaque dame spécialiste
du moyen-orient le royaume uni n'aurait
pas d'autre choix que de soutenir en
arabie saoudite on écoute le royaume uni
je ne pouvais pas refuser de l'argent
aujourd'hui et la vente d armes à
l'arabie saoudite est très pratique
londres a toujours suivi ce principe
l'arabie saoudite est un allié très
tactique est intéressant dans la région
le royaume uni est donc prêt à détourner
le nez regard face aux crimes commis au
yen elle est la logique sous jacente est
un peu biaisé souvent le gouvernement
adopte la position suivante comme le
gouvernement du yémen est considéré
comme un gouvernement illégitime alors
tout ce qui pourrait arriver à ce
gouvernement ou aux individus qui lui
sont liés il n'a pas l'importance de
leur point de vue car ils considèrent
soutenir le pouvoir légitime au yémen et
les se considère donc pas comme opérant
en dehors du droit international c'est
une voix lui très biaisée laisser celui
qui adopte le gouvernement britannique
voilà qui vous pose ses conditions pour
prendre part aux négociations sur la
suite du traité new start il s'agit d'un
accord russo américain sur les armes
nucléaires
pékin se dit désormais disposé à
discuter si washington réduit son
arsenal aussi la chine augmentent le
sien mais qu'un prêt à dont donc à
discuter si et seulement si américains
et chinois dispose du même armement
nucléaire et la medjahed
la chine s'est dite prête ce mercredi à
se joindre aux négociations trilatérales
sur la prolongation du traité new start
une condition imposée et pas des
moindres pékin veut obtenir avant la
parité des arsenaux nucléaires avec les
états unis et la russie
sans ça les autorités chinoises
considèrent n'avoir aucun intérêt à se
mettre autour de la table and for de
même pour les états unis demandé à la
chine de participer aux négociations
dites trilatérale n'est rien d'autre
qu'un stratagème pour détourner
l'attention du monde pour déplacer les
responsabilités et pour créer un
prétexte leur permettant de s'éloigner
du new star comme ils l'ont fait pour de
nombreux autres traité de contrôle des
armements vis-à-vis mais la priorité
pour nous je le répète et que les états
unis et la russie accepte de proroger le
nouveau traité start et sur cette base
nous espérons que les états unis et la
fédération de russie continuerons à
réduire leur arsenal nucléaire afin que
la chine y participent
lorsque leur arsenal nucléaire sera
ramené à un niveau comparable à celui
des ogives nucléaires chinoises tendar
toile à vos propos
la chine semble toujours faire de la
résistance aux invitations de washington
le mois dernier à vienne les états unis
et la russie ont repris les pourparlers
sur le contrôle des armes nucléaires
stratégiques pékin conviés à ce rendez
vous n'a pas fait le déplacement
une absence dénoncé alors par
l'émissaire américain nous avons
clairement fait savoir à la chine que
nous attendons d'elles qu'elles honorent
concrètement son obligation de négocier
avec nous de bonne foi dans le cadre du
traité de non-prolifération
elle s'est engagée sur une voie qui mène
droit dans le mur même si le débat reste
vif sur la place de la chine le dialogue
devrait se poursuivre au cours de l'été
le temps presse puisque l'accord new
start signé il ya dix ans entre les
etats-unis et la russie expire dans sept
mois
ce traité de réduction des armements a
permis jusque là de limiter à 700 le
nombre de lanceurs nucléaires
stratégiques et à 1550 le nombre de
têtes nucléaires déployées sur ces
lanceurs le traité ne concerne pas les
armes nucléaires tactiques de moindre
portée et ne limite pas le stocks
d'ogives nucléaires inactive
en 2020 les américains et les russes en
dispose de près de 6000 contre seulement
320 pour les chinois new start c'est le
dernier accord de contrôle des armements
entre washington et moscou encore en
vigueur
le président américain donald trump a
déjà écarté les etats-unis 2-3 traités
internationaux de désarmement dernier
retrait en date l'accord ciel ouvert qui
lie et 35 pays et assurer des
possibilités réciproque de surveillance
aérienne mais pour claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales la
position américaine russe sera difficile
à infléchir le vrai sujet c'est est ce
que le président qui sera en charge au
mois de janvier prochain à washington
considère ac l'intérêt des états unis
c'est de renouveler ce traité ou bien
est ce que monsieur trump qui sera peut
être réélu ou qui aura peut-être
dénoncer le traité start
auparavant considérera il vaut mieux
sans se livrer à une course aux
armements
puisque il ne tient pas compte d'un
certain nombre de nouveaux armements et
surtout de l'émergence de la chine
elle a l'intention en effet d'accroître
le nombre d'ogives nucléaires qu'elle
détient et qu'elle s'attend à ce que le
nouveau nouveau start qui pourrait être
négociée entre les etats-unis et la
russie d'ici le mois de février qu on se
consacrerait une réduction des stocks
d'ogives
américaines et russes et des fusées qui
permettent de les envoyer de les
délivrer c'est évidemment parfaitement
illusoire
une menace qui n'en est plus une ces
faits les états unis entament leur
retrait de lots oms
un retrait qui sera effective dans un an
et qui marque un revers de la
coopération internationale selon le
gouvernement allemand
on le rappelle donald trump reprochent à
l'organisation mondiale de la santé une
gestion trop tardive de la crise du
corps d'un virus le candidat démocrate à
la maison blanche dubaï dan a aussitôt
réagi les américains sont plus en
sécurité quand l'amérique s'engage pour
renforcer la santé mondiale
le premier jour de ma présidence je
rejoindre l oms et réaffirmé notre
leadership mondial
mais la proche des élections
présidentielles ce retrait politique
selon pierre guerlain professeur émérite
de civilisation américaine à
l'université paris-x nanterre
je me retire de toutes les organisations
internationales
là il s'agit de l' oms alors l'eau mais
ce n'est pas une organisation parfaite
et quelquefois les proches de la chine
c'est indéniable mais l'om est ce aussi
est une organisation tout à fait
essentiel pour assurer la santé dans le
monde et notamment dans les pays acp les
plus défavorisés ces pays par exemple
d'afrique que jobs avait insulté d'un
non vulgaire il n'y a pas si longtemps
donc c'est évidemment une excuse pour
masquer sa propre gestion catastrophique
de la crise du mobile aux états unis et
aussi solidifier une partie de sa base
électorale autour de la xénophobie en
prenant cette fois ci la chine comme et
non plus le mexique ou les pays
musulmans comme bouc émissaire et le
président libanais michel aoun a reçu
l'ambassadrice américaine cet après midi
elle est venue accompagnée
le commandant des opérations militaires
des etats-unis au moyen-orient lors de
cette rencontre le général mais kenzy a
souligné je suis l'importance du
partenariat solide entre les états unis
et l'armée libanaise michel aoun a pour
sa part appelé améliorer la coopération
militaire entre les deux pays
et cette visite a suscité la colère des
libanais proche du hezbollah
ce matin ils ont organisé un
rassemblement sur la route de l'aéroport
de beyrouth
ils accusent le général mc kenzie de
s'être rendu au liban pour commémorer
l'attentât d'octobre à 83 une attaque
qui avait coûté la vie à 220 miles
américain et qui avait été revendiqué
par l'organisation du jihad islamique
affilié au réseau ball à écouter ces
manifestants c'est vrai que nous faisons
face à un blocus économique mais c'est
impossible d'instaurer un blocus contre
notre dignité nous pourrons toujours
avoir des positions honorables contre
eux ce à quoi ils ne sont pas habitués
nous pouvons toujours leur envoyer des
restes et des corps dans les cercueils
nous voulons dire à l'américain qu'il
n'a pas le droit de venir au liban
il n'a pas le droit de commémorer ces
dates insolent les américains nous ont
affamé et ont fait de nous des sans abri
y aller nous assiège toujours et nous
affament nous ont aidés l'ennemi
sioniste à nous frapper au fil des
années melbourne en australie
confiné plus de 5 millions de personnes
sont concernées les habitants doivent
rester chez eux sauf pour des raisons
professionnelles pour faire de
l'exercice ou se rendre à des
rendez-vous médicaux acheter des
produits première nécessité ça nous
rappelle quelque chose
une mise à l'isolément qui durera au
moins six semaines ce sont les 191
nouveaux cas en 24 heures qui ont alerté
le gouvernement sur la question de la
fermeture générale de melbourne
c'est une question dont le premier
ministre daniel andrews ma forme et bien
sûr sur la base de leurs conseils et des
conseils que j'ai reçu du médecin chef
alors c'était nécessaire j'espère que ce
ne sera pas aussi longs que les six
semaines annoncé pattes
j'espère que ce sera pour une période
aussi courte que possible mais vu la
gravité de
situation dans les classeurs initiaux le
confinement y la mesure la plus sage que
le premier ministre de victoria et ses
conseils auraient pu prendre
c'est la fin de cette édition merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve demain à 20
heures pour une nouvelle émission et
point complet à 7 heures du matin sur
l'actualité
[Musique]
ici au delà du cercle polaire sur le
plateau continental russe l'homme
extrait du pétrole arctique pour la
première fois la russie est le premier
pays à avoir une plateforme sous ces
latitudes
d'autres états ont fait des tentatives
mais ont tous échoué
[Musique]
les conditions de travail sont
extrêmement sévères c'est dangereux
la tension est maximale aux étapes
d'aproz le navire est très proche de la
plateforme à 80 mètres 1 0
on peut dire que la plateforme est à
portée de main
chaque jour qui passe est une occasion
de vérifier le professionnalisme des
équipes mais des imprévus surviennent
aussi
alerte à l'attention du personnel de la
plateforme maugeois ni immédiatement les
points de rassemblement
[Musique]
il
des ogm c'est la cerise sur le gâteau de
la culture intensive et chimiques il le
nombre de techniques pour faire des ogm
a explosé pendant les 15 dernières
années les ogm si tu as un outil c'est
tout ce qu'il a il ne pourra rien faire
contre la faim dans le monde puisqu'en
fait la faim dans le monde est une
question politique
alors ça c'est les ogm il ya également
le glyphosate alors le groupe 7 à usage
agricole
on pourrait s'en passer il ya des façons
de produire qui peut se passer de tout
est remis s'il ya des gens qui ont un
intérêt à ce que ces molécules hla
soient pulvérisés sur les champs parce
que ça rapporte énormément d'argent
peut-être que ça arrange l'industrie
qu'on parle que du glyphosate parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres herbicides
ils sont en jeu et le glyphosate est une
molécule qui est tombé dans le domaine
public n'a plus de problème dans tout le
monde peut en produire
il ya d'autres herbicides qui sont en
train d'arriver